all right and
we are live the last word with lor
cognito ibontes
and ty guy travis on that fresh youtube
friday morning campfire big special
guest you know but uh before we get into
that
let's start with the man of the out
first the cheetah himself how are we
doing sir
uh we're doing good woke up this morning
got a little breakfast in
um worked out the last couple days just
been sore off and on
nice yeah i'm trying to stay in pain i
like that
oh it was the funny thing because i've
been dragged the rowing machine that was
sitting upstairs downstairs now so i can
kind of do it like little
different hours from when my wife is
working and i rode monday
and then my wife and i went to work out
tuesday and we were doing a push day and
i was like my legs are weirdly sore it's
like we worked out saturday and we did
like heavy stuff saturday at a friend's
house i'm like why are my legs so sore
totally forgetting that rowing that i
hadn't done in a little while i was
gonna make my legs sore i'm like
and finally it clicked in later i was
like oh that was it and finally we're
both just like i was like i wrote and
she's like oh
she's like i thought you were crazy for
some reason like my legs are oddly sore
because i'll work i mean i teach and
everything but
my legs are sore but no other than that
just you know keeping up with seeing
if anything fancy is going to happen in
destiny i started mass effect 2.
all right yes i saw the next problem
mass effect 2 has begun nice nice goat
talk let's get it
yeah so it must feel good huh i'm about
six hours in
so not that far okay okay the opening is
just like hey what's up
just gonna yeah yeah yeah you're gonna
kind of kick things off real fast so
mass effect 2 got it going but what
about you travis no
i don't need to take up the whole mic
how you doing oh yeah i'm doing great
man i
just finished my review of chris tales
doing all the
the writing and everything and the
voiceover do we get a preview of that
score do we get to know how how it did
or can you not say yeah i don't know if
i'm allowed to do that
exactly that's the patreon to you so
we're not
jeopardizing this and career review
yeah but it will be uh it will be live
uh today at some point
once the video guys are done with it how
long was it that's what i was actually
kind of curious about it took me
47 hours to beat that game before i
started
completion or yeah i did okay i tried to
do everything so
the completionist run i guess 47 hours i
did all side quests
that's a lot bigger than i thought it
was it was pretty big i was told 30 to
40 and then i was ended
i was like all right i'm gonna wake up
today and just finish it on wednesday
and i ended up finishing it at like
11 p.m it took me all day playing that
final day so
uh yeah it's it was fun i'm sitting here
in my clean room it's like
super bright in this room and then if
you open that door and go down the
hallway it's like
pitch black because it's still night
time here
uh but yeah it's uh good to be back yeah
shout out to travis
yeah shout out to travis getting up this
early but we got a guest this morning
so let's bring him in welcome to the
last word episode number
159 solstice is still in its holding
pattern
season 15 can't get here soon enough and
sadly once again some people need to be
reminded to treat each other with
decency
it's not a hard concept just be
respectful to each other
this week we are joined by one of the
nicest guys you really don't want to
piss off
i've met him in person i was just glad
to get my hand back an old-school gamer
like many of us who played classic
beat-em-ups on nes
and has a ninja inside him just like
cognito
no for real this man took the fun of
beating people up on screen and
harnessed that energy
to become a true master of martial arts
he also decided to master another art
form
graphic design has been helping content
creators for years now as well
so let's welcome a man who could
deadlift a small car could fill a whole
room with his martial arts trophies and
another with the books that he's read
uh and it's all while his body is
working against him so props to that
his determination to excel at everything
he does is clear when you spend any time
with him
and he is always in it to help those
around him and build up others along the
way so without further ado
khan how are you doing sir
i am uh it's never been introduced like
that before i should be the cop right on
my website
i am doing well i am uh i'm awake
that's that's that's that's well he is
awake official
oh dude we're so happy to have you now i
met you a couple years ago
at guardian con with me and millions of
other people who pass by the booths but
no it's like you have been in the
destiny community for a while and just
yeah you've done so much quality work
and you mentioned a piece that was
really cool
at that destiny con that we met her gcx
i can't
not call it destinycon but
it's funny because i was looking back at
that gcx
and um i was just running around with
the camera and it was right before i
bumped into you
i'd literally have khan on tape like i
went to his booth
i'm like oh god what's going on you
shook my head whatever and it's funny
now just seeing things come full circle
he's
he's at the campfire with us fans so
this is pretty cool man
but uh yeah we got to talk so we got to
get into this game in history first if
you don't mind e
no no i knew you were going to jump on
this one so i figured it out for you
i was checking things out and uh
speaking to the gaming ninja soul here
you know
he has some some specific choices that i
wanted to talk about
obviously you know i'm not a cognitive
gaming ninja my namesake is based off
that shinobi one of my favorite games
but the man also had ninja gaiden but i
gotta give him props on two games
that i haven't seen mentioned in a while
one tenshu
which in my opinion is true ninja
stealth like it might like the true
representation of it in video game form
and then the second one was a little gem
for sega heads which was shadow
so i gotta talk to you about those two
man tell me about those
in your gaming history oh man
the first time my buddy showed me ten
shoe stealth assassins i was like
oh man that's pretty cool i like that i
was like but i kept getting beat up in
the first time i played it
i gotta actually sneak up on these guys
and you know that led to me like getting
really into the game
and like sneaking up behind people and
then they released
a couple like subsequent sequels on a
ps2
and my favorite ones where they released
the uh the masseuse
called test shield he had the massage
needles he was like a acupuncturist
yeah he was just he was a straight up
ball dude he was kind of jacked
looks like me now actually
he manifested he would like breach it
behind you and they would use x-rays
when he killed these things first with
the x-ray kills and you see his hands go
inside my rib cage and then all their
brooms would break
at the same time yes that was the most
common before
ever yes i think it might have been
i don't know i'm not sure if x-rays came
up before or after but
that like cinched the nail for me but
i've loved that series ever since until
like it's
i think they had the last name releases
like you could beat any ninja and it
wasn't as fun
yeah yeah i think they even had like a
co-op one at one point
i'm gonna say xbox 360. then it kind of
faded off but
salute all you were that yeah man
because again you nailed it like
at that point ninja games were kind of
always like very fast
action-y but i never really thought they
captured the essence of the ninja which
is stealth sneak around deception
use the little rice trails and doing
things to get people off their beaten
path
and sneak behind them get some little
cinematic kind of things so
salute to you all that and i gotta i
gotta follow again with that shin moon
talk to me about that why was [ __ ]
on that list cause she was important to
me but i wonder why i supported you
oh man when i first got dreamcast and i
saw the trailer for shin mew
i was like this game looks amazing it
was so ahead of its time graphically
storytelling yes um if you would
if you would bring it if you just play
it now like it's like you look at like
oh yeah when this game came out you know
you know ps3 no this came out before the
ps2 this thing was
so ahead of his time in the story that
like all everything was voiced
all the characters were voiced yeah so
you used to playing morrowind
and you know all those other rpgs they
were like oh you gotta read the text
let's see one line read the text this is
like almost every single line of
dialogue
in the in the game was voice about
a character and it was one of the games
that had video games inside of video
game which was kind of better
he goes arcade and like play like
old-school sega games inside of the
arcade and you play like gotcha games
like but dropping in some quarters it
was
it was it was the game that made me say
on that day
for like a whole two years [ __ ]
playing that game because
every time he would interview somebody
like on that day
like because he's you know his dad got
killed in the game so yeah
he's trying to figure out who killed him
you know part two
was
it was a game what about three did
either of you guys ever play three
yeah i have it isn't that like a sad i
waited for to come out but i
i i couldn't get i forgot we'll pop it
in part two so i
i didn't pick it back up yeah you know
what it was e
all right this is gonna hurt because
it's like everything khan is dropping is
pure knowledge right
it's from the the original shenmue was
so ahead of its time
right graphically and like you said the
npcs
i mean it you really you even had to get
a job in the game
and wake up and go to sleep it was
really doing things in the open world
space
and graphic i think it was using like
am2's engine with virtual fighters which
was amazing
at the time what has happened since then
is i love you because you i used to go i
love maybe some uses
users who can get got me in the game so
i'm going to be respectful as i possibly
can
however three to me
feels like that's just
by a bit you know that that that i feel
like it just
hasn't caught up to what's going on now
and it was funded by playstation you
know to kind of help him get across the
finish line
so that's what i would say to it but
yeah it's for the nostalgic heads yes
they will love it but
to anyone new to the series they're
going to be like okay this is kind of
clunky a little antiquated
with certain things but i always loved
the martial arts influence
and then the fighting systems and things
that they put inside of it so yeah but
if you
if you if you find shenmue boring you
should
you should uh still thank it and respect
it for giving us yakuza because i don't
oh
that's just see agree that's the
spiritual successor to what shimu should
be
perfect analogy traps i agree okay
travis got a question for you show us
what you got for the con oh yeah
i was gonna ask so now that we know how
you got into uh gaming obviously the
community and destiny knows you for art
so
could you tell us a little bit about uh
how you got into your artwork
that you're now known for oh um
that's an easy question to answer
because it's not that long ago
i got into playing the destiny beta and
uh i fell in love with the game started
playing it you know
like pretty heavily i by the time i was
i wasn't back into doing art yet so it
was still a long long go for
i got back in and then i started seeing
like you know fan art
on actually destiny's the game that made
me get a twitter account so i could
follow
uh the um
the guardians podcast um by mark tarka
at the uh
garden radio the legend yeah yeah
so that that's what made me like you
know put together like a uh
a twitter account i was like i think i
was like i actually my first
twitter handle was iron lord khan that
was my uh
that was my freaking uh my uh my handle
in there
and uh so i've seen all this fan art and
i see some stuff on instagram by cobb
one
i'm like oh man this stuff looks like so
good i would love to get back and do an
art
and uh shout out to cobb push come to
sub i i
i got very very sick that following year
like right when king's fall came out
um i got really ill i came down with
muscle disease
and that put me in the hospital when i
came out i shrank up i lost like 50 or
60 pounds
um i went from like 215 to like
160 because i couldn't swallow food or
water wow
brother but i was like i just need to
get back into doing something i can't
lift
i can't do martial arts i can't body
build and i can't fight
i need to do something so i started
doing art again doing fan art
and uh like doing like watching cop arts
uh cobb ones like art on instagram like
catapulted me into like buying a um
a refurb laptop and getting back and
doing uh
illustration again which was uh
it was a challenge because i couldn't i
didn't have a tablet yet
right so everything i drew on there was
all like track pad
so i was like taking my time doing that
for a couple years four not for like
for a few months not a couple years like
four four months or so
and then decided to take it seriously
and be like all right now i gotta get up
yeah
tablet and all the gear yeah man that
was like that's after taking a decade
off i i didn't do anything i didn't make
anything
for a decade before that wow like i was
really a whole 10 years
wow if if you mind me asking because you
really drop
you know obviously a powerful story just
now in reference to the condition like
how did you mentally get through it and
then also on the physical side just to
get yourself
you know back to where you needed to be
as well as you know just going through
this condition just enduring that like
how did that uh process go for you
um luckily i already encountered a bunch
of hardships
and my mantra is you know i'm not gonna
curse in your podcast but
i didn't come this far to effing fail i
did not
i've crawled out of too many holes to be
stopped by
you know some disease so talk talk you
know it's
all it's it's autoimmune so like
anybody's gonna kill me it's gonna be me
and i guess it will be because it's an
autoimmune disease
so that's what i do i know what you read
i i i share one as well
you know so it's it's it's tough it's
tough but
having that mental toughness and like
you said you know not allowing that to
conquer you
you know what i'm saying and still you
know persevere and and do what you're
doing now is tremendous so we got to
salute you on that
because that a lot of people would break
during that condition and you
use his motivation man and it's good to
see you know what i'm saying you
persevered through that
yeah it's like if you don't have that
history and then you go look at your
twitter thread and i mean i joked about
you dead lifting a car but
i mean one of the recent ones was dead
lifting
4.95 like you hit it twice for a couple
sets and i saw that and i was just like
damn and just to not even not have the
other piece and know that that's what
you're doing now
but that's a hell of a lot of work to
get back to where you are and that's
just impressive and goes to show more
about your determination to
power through and say does it yeah
it was at the at the low point um before
i get into like
i was uh put in the hospital i couldn't
use my arms to push myself
out of bed to sit up in the morning so
i'd use all the abdominal from the
my triceps and atrophy completely wow
so it when i went back to the gym after
after the surgery the surgery
um it helps curb the
these these symptoms of the disease okay
so
they i got six cuts on my side and they
pulled out my thymus glands called
thymectomy
and so when i got back out and though i
got healed up and i they said i could
move around again first thing i did was
went back to the gym and i was doing
like
push-ups with my knees except for i was
in my belly so i couldn't do knee
push-ups it was there were belly
push-ups
and eventually after like you know 90
days of doing like
a one or two like one to five like
actual push-ups
i just kept going from there the triceps
will never be the same like i will never
be able to like
bench close to 400 again it's never
gonna happen but the muscles are just
i'm getting too old too gray and the
muscles will never be the same
i don't see a whole lot of grey in that
beard you're doing fine
you doing more than five brothers it's
the lighting it's the lighting
it's designed to help
that's what i want to hear yes anybody
who throws nes in there i'm like yup
you're about our age
cause i'm 38 and i just turned so i was
like we're right with you
no doubt absolutely look at the
sideburns i'm like
damn that one's actually real you guys
are cold
yeah travis is all like awake with all
this energy
because i got stuff i got more stuff for
god after you no but i mean i wanted to
kind of go back a little farther like
one thing you mentioned and it's
probably where some of your
styling and everything comes from is
your martial arts just i mean you've got
almost 75 trophies you said you've been
doing it forever like what is
what type of martial arts you do like
what did you take it through and i'm
just kind of curious what are some of
your like proudest trophies that you've
got from that piece of your journey
oh um i started off doing no event
shaolin
i'll start doing karate like most people
it's kind of hard to find
uh kung fu schools i started doing
karate around you know
seven or eight eventually i got into
like doing
uh northern shaolin in middle school and
high school
uh i did that you know competed
and after i went to college i got out
and i started learning
kuntao salat which is indonesian and i
got into doing mongolian
wrestling which is how i got my nickname
nice um
it's for i was like literally at that
point i was just like
got like 215 200 and i was just
training it just to you know kind of
break up the things i was doing
and i would just pick people up and you
know slam them down
and i got the nickname khan because i
would just throw people around all the
time
the only technique i didn't get the
technique down for a bit because it's
just very strong yeah just bruised
i'm like need to relax i'm like i am
relaxed
so that's that's like a nickname but
i've been doing like softer martial arts
since then so i i
took uh i'm transitioning to doing stuff
that was
softer because you know if you get older
you can't be you know striking wood and
hidden concrete yeah it really wears
down in your body after a while so i
started doing
chin style tai chi okay
just to ease it out because i was
already power lifting
and power lifting on top of doing like
extra hard stuff in your body is bad for
your joints so a little bit softer stuff
better for my knees elbows yeah it keeps
me uh
from you know everything seasoned up in
the arthritis taking over
mm-hmm i don't know about that plus 40
something to know about that
you're taking taking up bad shots in the
ring you're like i can't do this again
i can't get in the ring again like no
i'm like oh my [ __ ] you could beat me
up i'm like i'm not pranking you to
cheer by now i'm like i can't
be moving around with you guys i might
pull something
like i got a crimp stay there hold on i
gotta work out this cramp
i will take you down once i'm ready
that's why i stay hydrated i gotta
grab one absolutely
that's that's respect of the body no
doubt
on that thing i'm sorry so here no no
i don't really have any uh a lot of the
trophies i threw away though
i don't really have only only i kept
with the medals and like a couple small
ones
um because they're like once you get you
stop competing
and uh you can't look at all this stuff
it's like it's it takes up so much space
number one
number two like looking at old trophies
it's kind of like
it reminds me of the guy that was in a
napoleon dynamite you see that movie
yeah yeah he's like
i i was like his uncle or something i
bet back in my day i could throw
a football over that mountain i was like
i wanna be that guy i don't know
yeah back in my day i earned all these
trophies
what do you do now i eat donuts
i don't it's the trophies they they
serve a purpose when you're that age
when you're going through the things
it's like oh this is fun
now i'm like i could tell people i had
them it's not important to show
like a bunch of like mess that's a bunch
of like plastic and wood that
it it served its purpose but it's
living in the past living on your past
accomplishments don't really you know
don't really propel you forward that's
true i spilled all that junk
i'm the same way khan you win those
trophies so that other people can't have
them
that's really it
it doesn't matter what happens to them
once you get them it's just as long as
they can't have them that's that's good
you go down actually give a good amount
of more weight too yeah i give a bunch
of weight to my students
salute man let's let's let's keep this
uh martial steve for a little bit
um so one thing i respect is those
wednesdays i'm feeling that and i also
saw some
uh run run short flick sir so we got to
talk about that
um big fan of that that that era that
genre so i just need real quick
some favorites cause this is speaking to
me now i'm the guy who bought these
flicks
uh really like you know five daily
venoms and all this good stuff so talk
to the
car wednesdays and the run run show give
me
some top films for you oh top
probably number one film that got me
into like i was like i have to get kung
fu class
that's what i got shaolin versus wu-tang
or vhs
and i was like i've got to learn sheldon
that basically propelled me into that
so that's probably like my my gateway
drug was gordon liu gordy lou baby let's
go
educate e oh it's it's
it's a hole to fall down like it's it's
it's definitely
i've i've probably seen like almost the
entire like shark brothers like catalog
at this point
half of it um
so this isn't this this the second one
probably is like
kid with the golden arm oh that's a
classic guys let's go
okay he's speaking my language i gotta
get king in here
was like he's like my he's my hero okay
he's one of the places i got i started
lifting so much i was like okay
the guy he plays he plays the toad and
uh yes yeah he's flattered
botherly was the toe big boy my buddy
was like why do you like that guy so
much he's the guy that always dies first
i'm like yeah but he's such a badass
such bad their power would be
impenetrable
well this is fine continue to continue
this is my star wars travis
to speak to anyone who speaks this
language continue
everyone that says they're like five
deadly venoms i'm like oh yeah finally
vims is good
it's a classic but the one that's above
that for me is uh crippled avengers
like that movie the the entire five
deadly squad is in the movie
except for they don't have they don't
have like the powers they did in the
other movie
they all get injured by a guy who has
uh no arms he's a guy who has no arms he
has metal arms
and all these guys are like they this
guy blinds them he like breaks their
legs he like crushed their windpipe he
like breaks their skulls and then they
go and get this master
and this guy who they turn the guy blind
he becomes like a a master of like
with a staff at being blind another guy
that he gets iron like he got chops got
his legs off he gets iron legs
they all get these like these they they
rise up from this catastrophic event
they didn't know kung fu
exactly they come back and just
wreck shop over the entire like evil
gang i'm like
this is like if that's not motivation if
you're like having some some health
issues i don't know what it is
good point good point good point yeah
yeah man you you
you dated some fire ones man like yeah i
was watching uh a couple of streams and
i saw them playing in the back and then
then he had to woo the match i see some
meth some ray
gordon so it was a vibe and and for for
people of my generation
that's why wu tang actually means a lot
because
shout out to rizza who was the dj he
implemented a lot of these
shaw brothers these famous film
influences in the hip hop
so it was a nice this unique marriage
you know saying of hip hop
the kung fu flakes and all that stuff
but uh it's not the grip blaze in the
chat he said wu-tang y'all
like me yes yes we all talking right now
but yeah
it's respect man and that's why people i
think that's another reason why besides
the fact that
the lyricists of wu was just amazing
that's another reason why i think the
group has transcended because of that
that implementation of those uh short
flicks and classic kung fu films
so salute travis what you got because i
would take them over this whole segment
i don't
want to be rude no that's amazing
yeah i thought we i thought we'd maybe
get into some destiny now
yeah there's a game
the game we play uh yeah i uh obviously
i heard your
your um your origin story of coming back
from defeat and
going to that gym and and uh and lifting
and all that and
and you sound like you have the the
spirit of a titan within you
although i know you're a hunter maine
which
is controversial to this group none of
us
are hunters but uh slander yeah
tell us a little bit about your uh your
destiny history uh where you started
with
it uh how you settled on becoming a
hunter even though clearly you're titan
um that sort of stuff go to it
oh man so i saw that i got
when destiny came out when when destiny
the beta came out
it was shortly after um
i had a breakup um of about they were
getting
like a decade or so i do things for a
long time before things fall apart
apparently
so it's like a decade he's committed and
then you know
i had my roommate had a roommate move in
it was like he started watching like one
piece
from the beginning and i was like oh
yeah i'll start i think i'll start doing
something else
besides sitting down here once you watch
one piece i need to be
about the exact same time and uh i got
into it and i was like
you know hunter titan warlock and i play
i got i had all three classes when i
started out
oh man hunters i really really like
hunters
and i might look like a titan but uh i
don't like to run into things
full speed it's not smart and somebody's
been in the ring
and been hit yeah you can res in the
game
you can't raise your kneecap get broken
off
so i play around corners i don't i don't
it's not it it looks like it's fun
and he gets back in the face i don't
i don't i don't live the titan way i
live uh
a little bit more strategically because
uh
that's how life runs life doesn't run
like a titan until you get something
are you replying to that is that
realistic
i mean op is fun in the game it is but
if you're going to identify with the
class
you know i was like triple jump you know
that's the old school triple jump you
know from like oh mike most video get
double jump from like yo mario and stuff
like that
oh yeah like i like double jump and
titans were like you know farting around
whatever that was keep this titan
slander continuing please
i don't know it was it was not it's fun
to play
it was fun to play all three classes in
d1 when i had the time
but i definitely was a golden gun main
in d1 because
it took some skill you know what skill
is
titans
yo travis is gonna have so much smoke
for you when you finish continue
that that hitbox and golden guns are not
that big
you have to aim and shoot things in
destiny one i don't know
if you slam if you like what i remember
i remember the exact day
that they added hammers to d1 i was
playing hammers
and i was throwing hammers and it was
killing so many people and i was
missing the hammer i was like that guy
definitely should have died
nope i was like i had 30 kills this game
and i died twice this is not correct
because i'm not even trying really so
oh yeah hammers were broken when they
come out but they were still fun
yeah but it was wrong oh yeah they got
things
[Music]
whenever i play on titan i'm like i can
get a lot more kills but it doesn't feel
as satisfying
it does not feel as satisfying as like
actually like
jumping through the air and just have
that golden gun pop
off and knowing you have zero armor just
zero
armor you you pop that super you are
gonna die
you are gonna die immediately you jump
up and pop it and drop all three guys
you're like
i am a god if you do if you do it with
the titan you're like
it's just supposed to happen i supposed
to kill the entire team this is this is
how this goes i cannot be stopped i'm
too fast
too strong and too much armor
interesting that's why it's not as it's
not as satisfying to kill people
right you might feel comfortable wants
to earn
his kills khan wants to earn what he
gets
your class sir i mean he's saying all
the right things that we get more kills
that we're stronger
we're all around better so i don't
really have any problems with what it's
doing
you know i i disagree that it takes
skills to get killed with golden gun i
mean anybody can shoot 1v1 me but like
uh
you know it's just i
i play a defender titan so my
perspective is completely different i'm
all about you know
dropping that bubble in the center of
the map and killing you all with a
shotgun so
that's uh that was my d1 experience oh
you're you're from police vibe i got you
yeah who walks towards the bubble in pvp
be surprised yeah i'm like oh man pops
they
pop the bubble i guess i'll go take the
zone
yeah i was like that's what you should
do but you there's always somebody's
like i can totally beat him
i can beat him i pop it on the zone man
pop it on the zone
we need to capture you pop it right on
the sun and then oh there's three zones
i just walk away
he's stuck in place to each point i have
seen a lot of people going into
challenge
i watch it every time i'm like
this is gonna be in portland
this is going to end so poorly i played
like bubble with like bubble titan i
didn't play dfp away but i would just
like
just because i didn't wrote i didn't run
shotgun i was like people running i just
punched the death
yeah like why are you just you could you
could have just walked away
mm-hmm you could have walked away and
like you know he did you remember that
old d1 map
with the uh the bridge in the middle and
yeah
it was it was like a old russia map with
the bridge in the middle and that's
where the uh the b
was i remember on that map when we play
control the
the b was right there in the bridge i
would just pop my bubble
and then sit there with a sniper and
just peek out of the bubble and just
type people around the map
and none of them would come to me
because they see there's this giant
bubble right on the bridge but it was
like all right well i can see everyone
from here i'm just going to start
popping heads
a lot a lot of great uh memories with
that but that was back when i was extra
i remember that was the uh that was the
first map i played when they released
that
um that gunsmith uh gun that was a
sniper
it was the irene and it had lucky oh i
missed my iron
so much oh god dude that map is super
underrated
somebody i mean looking at that map now
playing it like
in just uh in in uh in local co-op not
gonna go out but
played a private matchup on that you
know d1 i was like this map
i thought it was so much bigger back in
d1 i went back and played it again i'm
like this map is so tiny
yeah this method is so small one bridge
two buildings be done
yeah maybe that's why i liked it it was
kind of small although
some of the maps probably don't work as
well on d2 because you move so much
faster and all that stuff but
yeah easier to get across it yeah i was
going to ask
real quick before i give it to you but
um in reference to
hunter subclasses i know i know you said
gunslinger
i'm just curious specifically like how
did you how do you feel
about night stalker okay so i want to
know maybe does that
get anything on blade dancer like what's
like the second favorite subclass from
you
the hunter
[Music]
i'm not really good at night stalker
because it requires the wombo combo
right and i am not great with those
girls like hunters have like the worst
grenades in the game
yeah unfortunately like if you throw a
grenade
if you throw a grenade now like my
favorite strip mines at d1
but if you throw a trip mine in d2 all
the geometry is so complex that it
always ends up sticking a weird angle so
you can't get the kills you want anymore
unless it's like a flush wall so
it kind of ruins that grenade um
when i played nightstalker like people
throw down their uh
though i can't remember the fire on the
ground and it spreads out oh
yeah like before yeah the
wave yeah none of the grenades they
actually work once i'm trying to control
the zone like
like it's it's so not
i can't like i i don't wanna i don't
the was it in like running arc strider
or blade dancer
like blade dancer was fun um
strider i was like you got to do all
this maneuvering and like
jumping around and i just i just want to
just set people on fire so that's back
to god's like
no the reason why i ask because i'm like
you have a martial arts background so i
was wondering if
cause as a warlock i'm not gonna lie
there is a part of me
that really is tempted for hunter only
from the simple fact that i feel you
know nimble
ninja you know what i'm saying when i
see blade dance super reflecting
you know what i mean there's certain act
and then like nice stalker you know
throw the smoke down like a ninja poof
do a little tricks deception
so i was very curious i was like i
wonder if any of that really appealed to
but you you won't go back to just shoot
people with gold
actually way of the wraith was probably
like my second one then
okay because like the night stalker like
the the tethers just they don't they
don't work
yeah like a lot of the supers like if if
we're talking about why people
don't like play other classes while
they're so much superior
our classes like the hunter classes are
they've been nerfed down so much they
just they just feel weaker
like if you try to tether a titan he's
going to be out of the way by the time
you shoot it in his direction or in
front of him he's just moving way too
fast
and you know arcstrider
it can be great if you get somebody like
in a room but most times people would
just run like
it's like hundreds believe there was
mobile class in the game but
hunter like but titans and warlocks and
both out maneuver them
unfortunately in a way yeah you're right
yeah you're right yep
it's that's like why do why why
like i i i can't stop playing on them
because i love them so much for why am i
being kicked in the face and like having
my mobility taken away from me
playing on hunter actually but you guys
are on the top of
the pvp boards man but uh just what you
don't put it oh you got to be
you have to be great to play pvp with a
hunter you have to be great
there there is no like you can't be like
okay and get by on a hunter
that's why we're characters you gotta be
you gotta be uh
mentally above the board
no doubt yeah i'll give it to you tell
you when i meet a great hunter player
oh my travis messi
i'm travis i love it
i don't know i was gonna ask um i don't
know how much you raid but if you have
any thoughts about kind of just top
three raids over the franchise since
you've kind of touched off and on a
decent amount of the franchise i don't
know how much you've rated but if just
like
big ones that we've been through and
stuff like that if you have any top
pieces before we kind of get into what's
going on this week like
what are the main highlights of the
franchise or like top rates for you
depending on how much you've rated
i haven't rated much at all in d2 due to
my time restraints but
i rated you know all three characters
you know
every week on uh in d1 so if i was going
back to d1 raids
um number one will be king's fall number
two will be vlog
and number three would be rather machine
rather machine and fall can be
can swap out though sometimes depending
on who i'm playing with
no doubt i can respect that respect he
loves this so
i'm i'm feeling this hey i got i got i
got a win
that's his raid that's his race travis
do you prove sir
i do approve i mean i don't take issue
with anyone who
uh says you know vaulted glass king's
full or wrath of the machines in really
whichever order
like no doubt as long as they're not as
long as they're not repping crota or
saying that leviathan's their favorite
one we don't have any uh
any issues there i mean it's just a long
strike you can run
it by yourself it's it was actually the
first dungeon in destiny
in my opinion oh i'm fully aware of
what's going on here it's fine
i've touched it before it's fine
[Laughter]
he just likes crota because it gave him
a chance to make uh how to solo crota's
and
yeah that's what i did too i did the the
flawless you know the flawless raider
achievement i just did croto by myself
that was how i got that
just yeah my money and i got it
i always thought thematically it fit the
hive very well because there was a lot
of franticness especially in the opening
i thought they kind of nailed and i
think it was big the big transition
from vex vault of glass all the
you know teleporting and portals and
confluxes and all that stuff
and they completely flipped the theme
really hard to go from vlog to
let me just hive just running at you the
whole time just the opening of that
alone i think fit the theme really
really well
yeah i mean it got to the point where a
buddy of mine we got our flawless thread
we two manned it and we're just like hey
do you want a two minute about three
hours later we were done and had our
flawless and it's just like
that one happened once you figured it
out but early on i still thought the
theme
it felt really good so yeah i know i
tell you it tells a cool story
it tells a cool story errors fire team
and then i will give you
it's like i would like to see the
opening i will say one other thing we
wouldn't have king's fall without crota
so oh for sure for sure we had to kill
you got it before
exactly got involved
yes that's correct well what else i was
going to say for the world of destiny we
do have some stuff going on
recently we got a fairly light twab but
we did actually get
some kind of twab um
biggest thing that started it though any
i was going to say i know travis is
going to be unhappy about this one
travis i can't wait to hear his peace
unraveling scent strands effective at
the start of season 15 we will deprecate
the passively earned world currency
synth strand that was used to purchase
armor synthesis boundaries from a to one
in its place bounties will be
purchasable for ten thousand glimmer
that's probably the most important part
of the twab so i'm just gonna prop this
one up to travis and
let you yeah this is all you man you had
it the most classic
last word rant this was about the flaws
they said that they were listening to
the community
and i happen to know i have insider
information as you guys know
that they were referring solely to my
appearance in the last word when i said
they've been missing the feedback
absolutely yeah cosmo messaged me and he
was like hey man
we got the message we get it
we're gonna change it just for you buddy
so uh
no seriously i think this is awesome um
it solves a few problems that i've had
with this in general
a the what i think actually ended up
being the biggest problem with
the new um system which is uh
the time gating right there was that
people discovered that
there was that time getting where you
actually had to be playing destiny for
like 10 hours to get 100
uh cent strands and then and then that
converted it to a bounty
so this solves that i think that that's
a big one to get off of the uh
list and then they also mentioned in
there we're getting rid of one of the
currencies so you have more space for
other currencies which like does destiny
have way too many currencies
yes is four currencies still too many
for transmog
absolutely but uh you know getting rid
of one especially the most annoying one
is not
bad news so uh this is great i feel
vindicated
um 100 they did it because of my
monologue
and um yeah i'm uh i'm
i'm i'm very happy it's a good start now
i just need to get them to kill maybe
one or two more of those damn currencies
uh and and we'll be in good shape so uh
but yeah
i i think this is a great uh they did it
faster than i thought they were gonna do
they didn't even let the full season run
so
uh hats off to them apparently their
thing is test stuff for a season then
roll it back out
cause sun setting three months this one
three months
but actually i wanted to ask on a kind
of a different take on this one
um transmog and kind of the eververse as
well
for khan as an artist all the work that
you put in
i mean obviously it's fair to pay
artists for their time and things of
that nature it's
you know it's like i've had people come
and be like hey are you looking for any
work and i asked them in the price i'm
like i don't want to do you injustice so
it's like it's better for me not to do
anything right now i'm not gonna like
ask for a deal i always feel awful doing
that
um please pay an artist for their time
they're always worth it trust me
um but that being said how what are your
thoughts about
just the way the eververse seems to
encroach and
everybody's you know sometimes it's like
hey we wish the cosmetics were outside
of everest and more earnable in the game
versus
you know how their business model and
stuff like that i was just kind of
you're curious
curious your thoughts on eververse and
just as an artist perspective
what that kind of how it all rings to
you i'm curious
um i hadn't had to like invest in the
actual money money into like
my uh transmog because
i only have like one look um only
transmog like one set of armor
i don't have a bunch of different looks
uh when it comes to every verse i'm like
it's not really changing the game it's
just their cosmetics
and if i really really want something
i'll buy it if i i don't i just
i just let it pass it's there's not many
things i seem like i need to have all of
these things
like in d1 i was completionist because
um i had time and i was healing
and i'm like um you want to run a raid
i'm like i don't have time to run a raid
how about i just play pvp for five hours
that's right time i didn't ask you for
your opinion
now you want travis back now you want
travis back you're good that's perfect
there we go yes it's i mean
you don't need to have those things they
don't make or break the game
um and when transmog came out oh that's
exciting
and now i got all this i've got every
bounty i've ever run
i've got like all this sin strand and
stuff and cord all piled up to the
ceiling
cause i've transmog you know literally
all the blue like the blue armor i
wanted to wear
and nothing else so it all depends on
how much you need to
you know how into you know dressing up
your your guardian is i'm just like
you know if i wanted to want it i mean
if you're and if you're
you know fun in the game i mean if i
like i like i have all these extras on
my website you can buy
and you don't need to have them but
you know it helps fund the cause of my
business and it helps fund like
all the stuff i do for myself and you
know everything else i do with my uh
my time why not
you don't need to have these things but
they're there
yeah my problem with transmog is that if
they would have just said
it's fully something you just have to
pay for i would have been more happy
than what they ended up doing because
what they ended up doing was being like
oh i mean you can earn it in game but
we're gonna make it at
as annoying and confusing as possible so
that you have to buy it it's like all
right at that point just
do us all a favor just sell it to me
then like that's what you if that's how
you want this to work
then just sell it to me so uh i just
think it does
it does wonders to make it less
confusing and uh
you know but this actually makes it more
these steps is possible
exactly stretch that content as much as
they can
oh yeah transmog if you get it like in
one step you're like
oh what i do now yeah
transfer a full set of armor had more
quest steps
than uh the curse of osiris
you know what i mean like that whole
campaign
had like four missions and like
transmogging a piece of armor
has like 15 quest steps it's it's
ridiculous man
so anyway i'm starting to get uh the
vapors again i need to come down
no you're good you're good you're not
bad you're big
uh but they basically mentioned they're
like removing this currency also frees
up a slot in the consumables inventory
bucket a bucket that could be full for
those of you who are carrying around a
large
quantity of items i'm like why is the
fact that my tab of consumables is ever
close to full
there are too many things so i'm glad to
see one of them go
i still haven't even done the one bounty
i picked up just because i haven't run
that many nightfall strikes
i picked up one bounty and i'm probably
just sitting on a bunch of synths strand
i should probably buy some random other
bounties for like at least
crucible matches or something but the
the crucible ones are super easy i do
them without even like knowing that i'm
doing them you just if you
just hop into the crucible playlist you
get it done passively so
surprisingly um the raid ones are very
easy
i i mean i tried to race out the the liz
in there
and back for this some uh iop clan mates
i'm seeing in there um
it's really good because a lot of it is
like fire team based and just like
shooting things with different you know
um you know elements and stuff like that
but um you know to the overall thing
with with cindy strand i still laugh at
that at travis classic
set the stress set the weaves
he went more rocked on screen it was
classic but um no look
it's good to see them get rid of of
an extra step that i need to step you
know i'm not gonna
get them off the hook now just yet
because
you know to me this was one of those
things that
it was really vocal by the community
to say we don't like this right the
community was very
up in arms and look we get it it's
cosmetic we get it the issue just came
down to
most games with in comparison don't have
this complex a system
the way bungie has added this system and
at the time
like e man you were talking i've never
seen when the committee was that outrage
them go
completely silent and retract right
so to me when i saw that action i go oh
this is from the higher-ups this this is
from the businessman of bungie that's
like look
you have to figure out a way to monetize
this if we want to keep the lights on
respectfully you know but at the end of
the day you know look it's a business
i get it you know what kind of thing so
my prediction was
they're really not going to roll any
much of this back right
so it's that way what is it three months
later whatever whatever and it's like oh
by the way
you know what cynthia we did realize
that was a bit oppressive so
you know what we'll touch this one
minute aspect
of the thing and then go you know okay
here's your victory i think that's
what it really is i think at the end of
the day look this is a business you know
they're not beholden to activision which
we will get into later
you don't say anymore they're on their
own you know what i'm saying independent
studio
and at the end of the day you know i
understand you know
the business aspect has to fund this
stuff in their defense not i've been
playing a lot
i've been doing these fairly easily
without thinking
like the bounty part so i will give that
for the people
you know shout out to my other fellow
fellow warlocks we we are shout out to
ira
dressed in the is a game for some i am
that guy i am ridiculous i have
an outfit for every subclass i have a
ship and a sparrow to match like i'm the
dude everything has to be lined up
per you know subclass so i am ridiculous
but at the end of the day it's good to
see them do at least something but e i
got to give it to you like e where you
at with this whole thing man
i mean it's a half step in the right
direction
i mean as you said like should this have
been this way from the start no we asked
for it for seven years literally out of
the gate oh look at all this cool armor
i want to dress up i want transmog
transponder come on
seven years later we got the worst
possible version i've seen in any game
ever
for transmog we did and it's like okay
so you got to go through this 150 thing
it takes you
25 hours or whatever to collect one set
of armor for sin strength then pick up
the bounties
the bounties aren't that bad unless you
get the first bounty i bought is the 40
nightfall champions one that's like the
worst one
it was like my first bounty is like cool
not that fun and i haven't even just
done as many nightfalls i've been doing
other stuff
and it sounds like some of the other
ones are not quite as bad but it was
just so
egregiously over the top as you said if
you want to do it fast
we're going to ask you to spend money or
we're gonna make it as you said the
one of the more ridiculous systems that
we've probably made when it could have
been
we already have a collection system
there's literally pages of
every piece of armor you've ever owned
copy and paste that into the other one
and just like
turn and you could and it's like it's
already there
and they made it much much worse than
they needed to and i think that was the
issue is like
you go in other games cool you got
transmog click click we just turned it
on
no no we turned it on with about 60
different switches and you got to cross
wires and you got to do these other
things and it was just
more convoluted when it needed to be
when it's something that could have been
a
nice gesture to the community when you
saw in the end it was definitely a
business decision
so when unfortunately now we're like hey
we do not have to do the
you know time-gated farming part which
is fine
it's still you know it's not the quality
of life is it better yeah are the
are the bounties that bad not all of
them it sounds like you can you know get
there
and it's going to be much more miserable
10 000 glimmer obviously to pick them up
during the course of a season it's not
that bad
but overall it's like it's still
somebody a new rat and chad also was
just like well they also got their
whales who really wanted it early they
got those knocked out they cleaned out
the whales if any whales wanted to be
like all right i'm just going to buy
like 50 cent
or 50 i don't even remember the currency
that you use to actually buy it
so many four cents right travis okay
strand cord and then weave i got to
remember together chords i forgot about
those yes
the strands is gone though now it's just
chords and weave and glimmer
yeah so yeah they still had you know you
can buy the synthwave from eververse so
the people they wanted to clean the
pocketbooks out
they cleaned out the early birds
now we're going to season 15. it's just
it is
been a very interesting year for what
have been larger decisions
between sun setting three months later
gone then we now we've got
transmog something we asked for for
seven years three months later stepping
it back and then i saw it in the
community as well
uh tassie was funny because he was like
just like
quotations like crying it's like we did
it we killed sent strand like it was
just a hilarious tweet because
finally that's the most the worst part
of this whole process is synth strand
but then on the other side it's how many
of these decisions and it might have
been destined honestly i can't remember
at legarry
um if it's not you sorry but it seemed
fitting
uh it was the point of like how many
times are they gonna come out with
something
the community is like hey some of this
is pretty terrible can we have some
changes and then three months later hey
we're gonna change this thing
like they they have to commit to it as
opposed to
just you know actually taking some of
the feedback the community doesn't
always know what they want
or what they need for that matter we
don't always know sometimes we do get
them right though
and this was definitely one of them is
so it's good to see some change
is it all the change that we'd hoped for
no but it's the worst step out of there
so it's at least
substantially better than it was so i'll
take that
yeah i'm willing to give them this one
just because you know they're kind of
damned if they do damned if they don't
sometimes bungie is you know they if
they don't do anything
then people go oh you're not listening
to the community you always say you're
listening and then if they do make a
change then the community is like oh wow
you
you just like cow toed to the to the you
know streamers who are asking you to
to to bend your way so i'll give them
this one it's a step in the right
direction and it gets rid of the worst
part of transmog
makes the process a little simpler i
will say one thing that i
i think they might end up taking away
from the season is that the
the armor cap that they're putting in
which is 10 pieces per season for this
season it was supposed to be double 20.
i think they're gonna they're the the
lesson they're gonna take from this is
that
oh it's plenty nobody did their full
allocation
like who here has gotten all 20 pieces
of you haven't even earned transmog like
none of us right like i i play the game
more than more than most people so
i'm willing to bet that the percentage
of people who got all 20 pieces is super
small
and they're probably going to use that
as a data point to be like oh yeah that
two
armor full armor sets limit like nobody
got the 10 pieces so
we can just leave that in place but it's
not it's not representative especially
once you get rid of synthetic it becomes
about you know you complete 10 bounties
in one season and you're done
um i'm hoping that that's not something
that they take away from this because
that was my first thought was
i bet nobody got the armor like
cap i bet you it's just such a small
percentage of the community so
uh yeah that's that's one thing i'm
worried about right and last point i'll
say before um
it's a cons point you know um the reason
why i don't go super hard on this one
like at the end of the day it is
cosmetic you know it does not affect
gameplay
you know so in that respect even though
other games have systems that are way
easier
you know i'm gonna be nice because again
i do understand
the jesus aspect listen i gotta get my
corporate hat on sometimes
no i'm just saying that's a corporate
car you'll literally go through the
comments on the podcast oh there's a
bungee shell he's a
bunch of apologists it's like you got to
be balanced at some point and that's why
it'll be balanced you know at the end of
the day
this is one of my favorite games and i
want them to exist
right and if this helps exist
and this helps give content then yeah
you know this
you got to have some balance in the
force that's all i'm looking at
but she's got to make some money to keep
making this game yeah
whatever they got to do to stay
independent now as we learned this week
yeah it's probably worth whatever price
do we want to tangent off to that right
now let's just
kind of open that sandbox um i'm going
to let somebody else open the sandbox
oh travis good jesus is working for one
of the biggest
yeah yeah what's going on man
something's going on yeah something
seemed to have happened with uh a
previous
friend of division destiny division
activision blizzard has a division did
you just say
yes this guy
just a mixed of destiny with
tom clancy's division tom clancy's ex
defiant
i'm sorry tom clancy's ex defiant
textifier you're
killing me you're killing me he just
commits he just confused the darkness
with the darkness zone this is
this is wild um anyway
uh yeah i activision blizzard large
company some people have heard of them
some people play their games you know
uh call of duty it seems to be doing all
right
um they uh overwatch yeah i forgot about
that one
it's been a while since i thought about
that game um they
are in a bit of hot water because the
state of california is suing them
for having a quote frat boy culture
um and has a bunch of sexual harassment
allegations
and uh underpaying female employees
and treating them pretty poorly passing
them over for
promotions and all that stuff obviously
there's still allegations right now but
um it sounds like it was like a two-year
investigation and i'm
i'm sure probably will settle out of
court because it's gonna be
a dumpster fire but uh it's obviously
really bad and um i'm sure
bungie in fact i know that they are
because they're tweeting about it
but bungie employees are definitely glad
to uh
have been uh kind of detached from that
and they
they couldn't have done it at a better
time because now they're you know fully
independent while this is all going down
but um you know my my two cents on the
situation is it's probably
a symptom of of the industry in general
i'm sure it's not just activision and
also just all companies i'm sure there's
companies like this in every industry
that are
that have this sort of culture but uh i
don't know that anybody was surprised to
hear this about activision if you've
been to an e3 and rubbed elbows with
some of these companies you sort of
get certain companies vibes and you know
walking over the activision booth you
sort of get their vibe like that's all
i'll say about
like uh about that company so you know
um
i hope it turns out all right but uh you
know thank god bungie isn't caught up in
all this
and uh you know we're reading their
tweets now and seeing how happy they are
to be independent so whatever they got
to do man if you if you need to make
more microtransactions
to to stick out of uh out of activision
blizzard i guess it was worth it so
that's that's my take yeah let's get
caught in it i'm kind of getting a
chance to uh
see any of the news in reference to
what's been going on with this whole
activision blizzard stuff
yeah that was the uh the topic of my
comic yesterday
um so i spoke on it um
i haven't really been
on in line with like blizzard activision
since
they had that fallout with that chinese
player uh
i think last year before i was like
after that i was like all right i've
done
hearthstone since you know this is
erased
so they've already like you know pooped
the bed for me one time too many
after they find that player but this i
was like am i surprised
no sadly i'm just literally waiting for
the
the next person like they have this cod
partnership or whatever
you know what's going on like well you
know it's just
it's just an investigation doesn't mean
they actually did it i'm waiting for
somebody to be defensive about
activation i'm like i know what's
happening what's going to happen
and then i'm going to be horrified
because
you know some people put their their
content career
before you know being uh decent
so that's that's that's something i'm
i'm wary of is
people you know super deep into
agrivision's pockets
and invested in being defensive
of a uh a culture of you know
such horrid things so
it's uh it's a thing that it's not just
a symptom of
corporation or corporate society or game
or the gaming society it's just a
it's it's it's a it's a symptom of a a
sick
cult it's just a sick society it happens
all the place
every place all the time you still hear
about it very often
um unless somebody comes out and you're
like that person is lying
that's usually what happens until you
know you find the video evidence and
then
the emails pop up i'm like well maybe i
was wrong
so it's a sick sick world and uh
the more times this gets exposed right
now righteously
it's exposed um the more we can move
away from just being you know complete
you know trash people but you know until
that happens until people with power are
held accountable this is going to
continue to happen
i agree i hope this is like one more
step up the rung of like pulling
ourselves out of the muck
into the 21st century we're still
dealing with this and it's like
yeah we're never going to reach star
trek land this is never going to happen
we're never going to be at this this
level of
equity it's just at this point we're
just like hey are we still
in the 1940s 50s this is like this is
crazy
crazy to me but i mean
until somebody says something speaks up
more often
enhance receipts this is going to
continue to happen unfortunately
yeah it's it's it's this was this was
tough to read this was tough um
you know seeing the accounts and
everything and then you know the
frat frat boy kind of culture kind of
thing i think the thing that disturbed
me the most regardless of
you know anyone who says allegations and
stuff like that you know
one of the accounts of someone you know
a female losing her life and committing
suicide
that really affected me because at the
end of the day
you know we could say allegations and
you know all that one for people
who want to be defensive and that's fine
you know wait to the facts supposedly
all come out and stuff and that's fine
but that's where it hit different
you know that that's a different type of
culture where you know if females are
getting
abused in that way and and you know just
objectified and stuff like that
it's just is there's nothing there's
nothing to defend that part
you know and i i'm i was shy i was
shocked
in the sense that it was so
many different accounts you know i'm
saying and when you read them like i
said they're just
really upsetting you know they're really
upsetting the people of color
you know being being held back um
just you know people in authority and a
lot of what i consider grooming
practices you know i'm saying as far as
um you know people who are holding
position of authority
to to keep people because let's be real
like for someone who now
you know is really more in touch with
the industry a lot of these positions
are dream jobs you know you work at
activision blizzard you're making
and in the video game industry there's
really not a lot of them right
so people can be put in positions
where it's like man i i it's my dream
thing i don't want to lose this whatever
whatever
and to me that's how the grooming and
that's how this predatorial
you know culture can start so look you
know
part of me is you know happy that stuff
is out and
you know i'm very curious i'm going to
moderate to see what actually happens
when the litigation
if like travis said is it a quick settle
you know the same kind of thing
is it you know it all i mean in act i
think activision's initial statement
was kind of defiant kind of like you
know they were refusing
a lot of stuff and they were kind of
like look you know this is a gross
misrepresentation it's gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
what i the last point i make before i
give it to you e
what i found very interesting is that
all this prompted other
companies to be like oh yo by the way we
don't do that here
you know like regardless of that if it's
true if they're not doing it or not
i just thought it was interesting that
preemptively
other companies are like oh by the way
we here at such and such
do not approve of this that so that to
me
showed the ripple effect right that to
me showed
the impact of of of of what's going on
and like i said it's be it'll be very
curious to watch but yeah i definitely
want to get
you know your vibe your feeling on on
everything that you know once everything
the the accounts came out
i mean it's it's sad because you see it
more and more
in so many places and when some people
are like are you surprised and
the sad answer is no no yeah and that's
what you hate
is because are you surprised this stuff
happens no because it's not the first
time we've already heard about it
ubisoft still is another one that had a
big story come out
and then even you know schreier's
article saying it's like you know people
may be in power
still they may be going through like
quote training or whatever you want to
call it
but it just always seems halfway and
that's the hard part about somebody as
big as activision too they're gonna have
all the money thrown into their legal
department that they've ever had before
because they're going to try and defend
as you said settle out of court so many
of this is not going to be able to come
publicly to light and i mean it's
california so it has chances of being
public because it is actually just the
state
but still some of the stuff that you
read i mean they've got receipts
about promotions that they've been like
skipped over for be like hey here's a
marketing campaign of like
hey i did more marketing campaigns every
one of mine outperformed
the other guy he was still promoted
above me i mean that
unfortunately something that happens all
the time and it's like as a white
male guy here sitting talking about any
of this stuff i always feel slightly out
of context in any of it
but it's like my wife always on the
other side is always talking about so
many different inequalities and things
like that just for
equal pay and things like that and all
of those things you read about just like
document it over and over and over and
it's just everything to go
it's wrong and i was like that's why my
part in the intro for khan was like a
short piece because i didn't know if we
were gonna spend any time on it or not
but i wanna just
is it it doesn't seem so hard to be
decent to each other it really doesn't
and you read this and i'm going
it's a whole culture that's been built
up and as you said unless you can rip
all of the negative people out of an
organization somewhere it's going to
start breeding again
and growing and all of those other
things from the people that do remain
and that's the worst part is because
it's not going to go away unless you
just completely close activision
and you build up another company and no
company is perfect no one is perfect
by no means but on the sides where it's
the stuff that you hear him talking
about
as you said the person who lost their
life from going on a business trip
and then the other counterpart brought
like
things with them to like very much
indicate their intentions for that trip
and they're just like
i'm and you know sitting around the
office and drinking around the office
and passing on work while they go play
video games just all the things that you
read i'm like
yeah it's not that hard to try and pull
your weight at work
and then especially to be
about the worst bad way about it as well
to
anyone else whether it be male female
person of colors it
it doesn't matter it should not be that
hard to trend as you said their dream
jobs
it's a place they really want to be and
then another movie that made me think of
it as bombshell i don't know if you guys
watched that one
um that is to a point they want to be
that like
head you know dateline that face
reported that they want to be but what
they have to go to
go through to get to that position it's
terrible
and until people and that's the worst
part of all is khan as you said it's
like until enough people are going to
actually
stand up talk about it and on the other
side people are going to believe them
because you're waiting for that defense
to come up to be like
well you know because and all
and you're just like yeah it's hard it's
hard enough
for any typically any female in those
situations to speak up about it it's
hard enough to go through to that
experience and have them speak up about
it in the first place
but then when everything's always met
with disbelief in anything else it makes
it that much worse
so no it's just it's a terrible story to
read
and sadly it's not surprising because
it's in a lot of places i think alana
pierce had a video about her
experiences in different companies and
stuff like that that she's seen
people had a wager of who got to sleep
with her first
so i was like i mean you don't even know
what she didn't mention the company
she's not gonna do that but it's just
it everybody i was like unfortunately
not all guys
and that's what my wife is like i'm
happy i found like a nice one but it's
like
so i i don't know so often what happens
why so many typically males are dumb
asses and i'll use the curse today so
i'll do it for you kahn
but i was like i just don't get it so
that's that's mine and i don't even have
any perspective on it but i just i hate
seeing it because
you try and be decent but i'm like
there's it would be i don't
feel like i have any place to try and
fix this situation when a giant
corporation is awful to people
it's hard yeah travis was gonna jump in
yeah i was just gonna say because it's
come up a few times
uh about you know whether or we should
believe this or not and that sort of
thing because they're allegations but um
i for anybody who's who's trying to be
like level-headed and say like oh yeah
well
you know i'm not gonna assume anything
until it's proven in court
that can be a really tricky trap to fall
in and it's one that actually plays
toward corporation strengths because
no no corporation rarely ever is
actually going to let something like
this go to court because they would lose
more money so even if
it didn't happen they're going to settle
out of court and if they settle out of
court
all of the stuff that they're being
accused of doesn't become a matter of
public record and so
on one hand you have you know what cog
said activision saying hey this is
totally absurd this never happened and
then on the other hand you have them
paying out of court
and so if you say oh i'm just gonna wait
until this all shakes out
you're never gonna get your answer nine
times out of ten probably more than that
and so
the you know i'm all for innocent until
proven guilty i actually think people on
the internet are too
quick to pitchfork but when something
like this
you're dealing on one hand people who
feel like they've been wronged and on
the other hand
a faceless corporation that no single
person actually represents and so
i think the if you're citing if your
tendency is decide with activision and
consider the corporation innocent or
proven guilty i would just say that like
maybe your priorities are a little off
because you're not really defending
anybody right if i work at activision
and i read a story like this i also
would probably be
equally outraged and want probably even
more for the company to do better and so
i think that there's very there's a very
little wrong that can come of this
other than activision as a corporation
has to pay money that
for me something that maybe they're not
responsible for um
which you know i don't think that that's
the worst thing in the world because
activision's got money
uh and on the other hand you're dealing
with people and their livelihood
and their futures and all that stuff so
um that that's
one point i wanted to make the other
point uh was
first of all ign's reporting team got to
give a shout out to them because they
uh did some really great work on this uh
joseph noop and some other people
um uncovering this sort of thing uh
that that's a really tough topic to
cover um
and this i think in general the games
industry has been pretty good about
documenting some of the problems with
its industry uh which i
i'm i'm personally proud of uh because
i think we have a really unique problem
um
in the games industry which is that it's
an extremely young industry
and some of the people who are a lot of
the people that make up the teams they
are right out of college right or they
have that younger energy and so i'm glad
you said this i was about to go there
yeah this sort of culture i feel like
it's easy
it's not something that i think is like
set up
by the powers that be they go okay
here's how we're gonna do it all the
guys get promoted and you know all that
stuff
but i think it's something that sneaks
up on you because
everybody's just having fun and oh you
know i've worked at lots of companies in
this industry that
like drinking is part of the culture and
hanging out and then you've got
friendships that form and people
obviously want to promote
their own friends and so it's something
that develops over time and i would just
say this is a really good cautionary
tale for
any youthful cultured company in the
games industry
to sort of self-reflect and stop for a
second and investigate the way that
they're doing things
and i i think that this is good to do
every once in a while like
ign had to do it when the black lives
matter thing happened and start looking
at
who was in charge at their company and
it's not something where you go okay
well let's only hire white people but
like after time you kind of have to look
at your roster and go all right well
do we have some maybe unseen biases are
we doing stuff and
and i think that these touch points uh
throughout
the industry they are really useful at
making these companies sort of look at
their own culture and
fix it before it becomes a problem or
course correct and so
um i i view this as a good thing for the
industry and also
um think that we should have empathy
with the people that that
say that they're that this is happening
to them right and maybe not maybe not
defend the corporation you can still say
look i'm gonna buy activision games but
on the other hand you shouldn't
you shouldn't dismiss people that i
think uh
are are probably genuinely dealing with
some stuff
so anyway that's that's my diatribe i'll
get off my soapbox no no no you're in
your bag i'll finish i've been quick
because you
you touched on some points too you know
i mean we were fortunate to have
jason schreier on on arnold's podcast
and
you know his book press reset in
reference to the games industry
and you know you made a valid point you
know especially from
the youth involved you know and and
obviously you know the female
perspective right
you know in in the games industry and
things that they go through and
being that again there's not a lot of
options and
especially like you say whether it be
young or
you're just getting into getting started
in your career you want to do everything
you can
to impress and make a mark and
because again access is limited all
these things are limited
to these positions you know festering
fostering these cultures
you know what i'm saying these you know
kind of situations that we're reading
about
and yeah we need systemic change in the
game it's just it's just what it is
and especially with the volatility of
the industry you know a lot of these
games
you know they don't sometimes they a lot
of these there's more misses than hits
and studios closed down and stuff like
that
so again all this adds to that pressure
of
i got to try to do what i got to do to
to stay and survive and
and then situations can arise right so
there's still i know he's big on you
unionization you know in the games
industry and stuff like that
this what i'm hoping sets off a platform
of real discussion to implement real
change
to affect developers everyone in the
industry
so that look i love video games but i
hate hearing about this type of stuff
you know and these are the kind of
things that
would you know make me shy away from
trying to get a job in industry because
you're like yo who wants to
to deal with any of this kind of stuff
so it's a good talking boy travis i
think you made uh fantastic points
one other thing i wanted to say before
we close this up is i actually don't
think working in the games industry is a
dream job
whether it's this sort of culture stuff
and the hours that they have to work i
think it's a dream
industry but i think the vast majority
of people working in this industry do
not have dream jobs and i don't think
it's
super helpful to say that that like oh
it's a dream job like this is
something that you guys should be happy
with it's sort of just some they think
so though
it's a little bit of defeatist but yeah
they they they sort of need to
i mean obviously we all want to work at
bungie but even when you get the job
working on bungie
you're not you know unless you're luke
smith you're not doing all the things
that you want to do at that job so i
just think uh
maybe they they uh should get a little
bit more credit for the fact that
they're out there grinding too
you know those jobs aren't easy most of
them so
i was just going to wrap it up reading
what bungie tweeted so you guys can hear
their pieces that's great bungie is
built on empowering our people no matter
who they are
where they're from or how they identify
we have a responsibility to acknowledge
reflect
and do what we can to push back on a
persistent culture of harassment
abuse and inequality that exists in our
industry
it is our responsibility to ensure this
type of behavior is not tolerated at
bungie at any level
and that we never excuse or sweep it
under the rug while the accounts in this
week's news are difficult to read
we hope they will lead to justice
awareness and accountability
we have a zero tolerance policy at
bungie for environments that support
this toxic culture
and we are committed to rooting them out
to defend those who are at risk
women people of color and
underrepresented communities have
nothing to gain by
reliving their trauma we believe them
when they come forward with reports of
abuse
or harassment we don't pretend that
bungie is perfect
and that no one has experienced
harassment while working here but we
will not tolerate it and we'll confront
it head-on
and we will continue to do the work
every day to be better
our goal is to continue to improve the
experience for everyone working at
bungie
and do our part to make the gaming
industry as a whole to be more
welcoming and inclusive
so cool thought that was pretty well
said um
again nobody's perfect they're trying
their best of course as you said you
never know what's happened before what
happens behind the scenes what's not
reported
but again doing what they can being very
quick to head it off
that's trying to do at least everything
they can is their goal
so it's good to see bungie usually
trying to do the the right thing
no doubt no doubt so one of the reasons
why it's a little easier to support this
game sometimes
um moving on from
that very very slightly heavy topic to
say the least
um yeah it's kind of hard to move on but
we got to
so we've got some changes as we
go back into the twab two uh nightfalls
so they have double your fun next week
nightfalls will feature double rewards
we also have a mixed bag of rewards as
the palindrome the swarm and shadow
bryce will all be dropping
so everything is on the menu and with
double rewards if it's the opportunity
to
uh basically pick up the rules if you're
looking for either adding them to your
collection or hopefully getting a better
roll
and then they said speaking of nightfall
rewards starting in season 15 the
nightfall weapon rotation will be
changing
instead of six weapons in the one one
one
three weeks as they have currently for
the second half of the season
they will have eight total weapons in
pairs consisting of one newer
and one older weapon you might remember
the new weapons being replies from
destiny 1 as a hilarious shotgun and a
rocket launcher that was the ultimate
reward for doing the longest crucible
quest
each week one of these new weapons will
be featured alongside another weapon
already in the pool
so for example week one comedian and
shadow price
week two the hot head and hung jury so
the additions this season will have a
spicy part combinations
uh typical in nightfall loot uh
including a couple of perks not seen on
archetypes in the past
so back to a bit more of the game topic
after the heaviest conversation of the
day
um thoughts on the nightfall rewards you
guys kind of like the way they're
switching this up do you guys go after
any of these nightfall rewards in
general or where are you guys at on
these
you're coming in man where you're at
with the the nightfall stuff
i'll only chase one gun so i'm done
i was the only one after the plug one
plug
which one oh yeah plug one that was the
fusion rifle i used in d1 where
i will consistently get six like six i
would get team wipes for that one so
it's not the same as it was but
it brings back old memories nice and
hung i got a hung jury but it was like
scouts aren't that great right now no
yeah
maybe someday but right now hung jury
isn't even that good among scout rifles
no it's not but shotguns and rocket
launchers i'm like
i can't use shotguns i'm terrible if you
get i got to fill winters i couldn't
kill you if you were standing
if you were face to face with me from a
foot away if i fired a a phil winter
in your chest you would live through it
and kill me that's impressive actually
yeah
that sounds like it takes more stuff not
to play
yeah it's it's never been good i've i've
never had luck with shotguns
so what do you use what what just
curious out of your your loadouts like
when you're going into the pvp like what
what's the uh what's the con loadout
oh sturm plug one and uh crowd pleaser
oh okay okay all right
i see the vision okay this guy chain
reaction on it so it's
and you play control you you get you get
one or two it's gonna it's gonna spark a
flame like
look at that like popcorn
that's an addiction you get one of those
off for sure for sure it reminds me of
um
what's the uh the exotics uh sniper the
cloud strike
when you get one of those off those
feels good too as far as like the chain
you know reaction kill kind of thing
that's what's
i've been killed by that in trials
somebody gets a cloud strike shot on you
and it just kills the whole team
it's brilliant that's what i need i need
that back of my golden gun i need
combustion back on gold
yeah uh for the changes i like that
they're expanding the loop pulls for
uh grandmaster nightfall again i i still
think that there's underlying issues
with this being the end game activity
you do if you're into pve
and i arguably that like grandmaster
nightfalls are
way more rewarding than raids which is
still crazy to me
um and and the other reasons i've
already talked about on the show like 50
times so no need to retread those but
you know what my issues are with them
um uh
to me the whole double rewards thing
they keep doing at nightfall it's just
like
you know how when they're out of content
they just do iron banner like every
other week
that that's what it feels like like you
know that the season's
almost over and that you're out of
content when they keep telling you
yo we got a we got double rewards in the
nightfall this this week it's uh
not something that uh that that i think
is super compelling content it's just
like all right we're out of stuff to do
for those of you who didn't do
grandmaster nightfalls hop in here and
and do it all this week so
uh i will probably not be doing this i
need to i
dude i'm still behind because i've been
reviewing games i haven't even
uh upgraded my blue armor to purple for
the uh
the solstice i still have blue armor i
don't think i've completed a single uh
piece of armor gotten it to purple yet
so
uh i need to do that and then and then i
can see what else is up with destiny but
yeah i haven't haven't had a ton of time
for destiny reviewing uh
two 40 plus hour rpgs back to back yeah
you've been a little busy
a little busy but yeah um i i i'm
i i think it's it's a minor improvement
it's good but yeah
i still all my problems from previous
episodes still apply with nightfalls and
where they sit
uh in the end game and all that stuff so
uh yeah that's where i'm at
yeah um you know double
double your fun yeah i mean i don't know
i mean
i really wasn't inspired too much
you know i've seen one hung jury and all
that stuff but okay cool
but you know this is this is reprisal
stuff you know and i'm trying not to be
super negative but it's just it's just
i'm not that excited and then the way
the perk combinations
you know worked i i i feel like there's
a lot of stuff they've added
in the per like now that they bring them
back like they've added
so many perks in each column that trying
to get a guy roll now
is like you know really crazy in his
activities and again to travis's point
i think that truly inspires like
we don't have a lot of content so keep
playing it to keep trying to get
better roles as opposed to you know more
of those condensed
you know maybe six to eight perks or
whatever it is per
you know gun that we're normally getting
and yeah i just
to me it's just trying to force
engagement again
and you know look comedian i remember it
you know i don't even remember hothead
surprisingly that's weird i don't know
do you guys remember that i feel like it
was almost a month
yeah it was like it was a long request
yeah it was not great from what i
remember
like i would do something else okay yes
i'm like
it just i'm like wow what is that i
guess i'm curious about it just to see
you're saying what what archetype and
you know obviously rocket launchers are
in a good place right now so obviously
it's just interesting i just like damn i
don't remember that one at all but
well then it's like you have a whole new
weapon [ __ ] yeah yeah for me right
but at the end of the day it's just like
yeah i'm with you trav
i'm like distilling in-game
content for me you know the same kind of
thing and i'm trying to be nice but i
just don't i'm just not i'm not i'm not
pumped
without but i saw this but e what you
got man
uh i mean at least for the rotations it
gives each week a little more value
because if somebody's trying to farm
shadow price then cool but if they don't
care about shadow price they're like
okay maybe i won't even mess with
nightfalls too much this week
don't even really need to put a group
together hunger as you guys said you
know scouts are if you got a decent one
you're good nate at least it gives you a
little more variety in your week if
you're gonna go play a few
you might get a little more so that's
not a bad thing i'm with you guys though
for me it's like
hey what are we getting for nightfall
rewards more old stuff
i mean that's it's more reissues the
i mean if you want to see somebody's
thoughts on reissues go look at cool
guys video on tranquility literally says
do not use this it's like yeah
the perks and tranquility are trash and
unfortunately from a gun that some
people really enjoyed to bring it back
in the state that it is now
you're seeing them kind of pull away and
reissue
some things in a worse state than they
were before
yes and that's almost
going the wrong direction in a weird way
that i almost don't know if i
expected for them to kind of manage
their balancing in that way
but i guess i also kind of expected it a
little bit but i have
like for example i have a retold tail
yeah
shotgun from dreaming city and my role
on that thing is
fantastic i still don't know if i even
have the thing but
i probably do somewhere buried and i
loved it it was a shotgun that felt
pretty good to me
had really good it had like the roll i
mean it was
rifled barrel range masterwork quick
shot it was
just about everything i could ever need
and i'm an okay pvp player so for me i'm
like
good doesn't have to be five out of five
it's probably four out of five but i'm
like i got that so long ago
json said it for three months and then
they go to reissue it and i'm like i'm
not gonna go try and get the same thing
i've already got and i was like
i told you guys when go figure comes
back as a reissue and i'm waiting for it
to do it okay
oh you know it's coming back no it's
coming your dad bod gun is coming back
yes
yes but i was like when that thing drops
again i'm just gonna be
it it's i'm sure it will feel like the
same gun but it's like for me to get the
roll that i got twice i got a really
good one and i got one like
the squeak better than the really good
one i already had i'm like i don't want
to go for it again so for me it's to the
point of this the in-game stuff for old
weapons
kind of leads me to where i'm going next
is at this point
i'm waiting for which queen because i
know season 15 i'm gonna enjoy the story
it's fine but i'm gonna grind nightfalls
every other week for like six months no
i'm waiting for which coin to put
new stuff in the game because this again
tells us reissues are still what they're
putting weight into and what they have
time for at this point it's like
the model's already built they i'm sure
they're i know there's definitely work
to bring it into d2
mess with the perks and make sure it's
balanced for the game feels kind of
right but
but existing assets so yeah existing
assets are there
and it's but also again we've we don't
need to rehash sunsetting but it is
the more we see this stuff i will be
curious to see how it goes
we're bringing d1 stuff up we've got d2
how many new things are we going to get
in which queen we're hoping a lot
to make it feel fresh but we also hope
that those new weapons have some fun
perks on them because if they do a
tranquility to the new sniper
then we're going to be really sad if the
new witch queen sniper is
you know tranquility level perks or
something we're going to be
less thrilled about going into the new
game with stuff that's not quite as fun
yo what's up destiny show
uh hello so i mean for me it's like it's
nice to see a little variety in the
nightfall grind
but i mean yeah you guys get hung jury i
see the rapid hit firefly i'm like cool
for a scout rifle it's probably not too
bad
might put in some work i have a night
watch that's plenty
it's like outlaw explosive rounds or
something it puts in enough work for
what i use it for but i mean scouts
aren't great we know that hopefully
we'll be seeing something
you know certain auto rifles yeah and
it's like hot head could get some
i will say the perks on rocket launchers
seem to at least be giving them a little
bit more fun
because they finally are bringing them
up so they're trying to give them some
life
but again we're finally waiting now for
machine guns to get their love that they
need so when those actually get a little
up we'll see if those get some perks so
it's interesting to see the way they're
like sun setting reissuing with worse
perks to do their weird version of
balancing again
it seems to be what we're watching them
subtly do
if you're not that deep into it you may
not notice but if you're like watching
like you know cool guys saying
tranquility sucks now that's when you're
like hey this gun's back don't
don't even worry about it yeah that
takes one less thing out of your grind
and if you see it drop you're like well
that's not going to be good so
yeah it's just one of those for me it's
like again we're half steps as i keep
waiting for next year
it's kind of where i am on some of that
stuff season 15 really seems like it's
going to be the awkward teen year of
destiny
like literally the thing i'm most
excited about that next season is
cross-play right right i'm not even
hyped whatever the content because i'm
dreading
because of that long gap now that we
know which queen is back and then
when you see these kind of things you
know again i'm trying not to be
disrespectful because i know
content takes time and stuff like that
but i always look at
this is a comp you know they're trying
to stretch things as
much as possible until they're really
ready
and and you know we talked about this
before eve at many times but just like
you know you jump in you do what you got
to do and there's other games to play
too also
you know if you're completely
dissatisfied there's no need
to continue my days of me getting angry
and all furious about it
that's a wrap you don't say i i know
what's happening here
i know that i read the temperature in
the room this
type of reissue stuff again all this
stuff screams
we're just trying to stretch this thing
out as long as as possible
you know with as far as the easiest path
possible i'm not a developer not saying
it's so easy to make
bring comedian back and all that stuff
but we know it's easier than making new
guns
you know the same kind of thing so i
just look at him like look this is what
it is you know i mean i log in my
tuesday i get what i get done
check the 12 i'm always going to be huge
for my sandbox and my pvp
stuff trav you know we're always going
to get excited you know i'm going to
jump in there i'm not going to go crazy
and i'm with e i think the changes that
we
truly want are what hopefully going to
be which queen that
that's those experiences are usually the
transformative
game play altering experiences where
they truly
take it with the sandbox and and add
stuff and maybe sub classes
and then we get that reinvigoration
again that we all truly want you know
what i'm saying from
yeah and it gives them six months or so
to figure out
cross play because i actually think
that's going to be a big deal that's
going to be huge
that's going to be huge it's going to
bring people together other games have
almost not survived implementing cross
play and i can't even imagine how
difficult it's going to be for destiny
at such a large game with so many
different so many different platforms
they support and that sort of thing
what'd you say nothing nothing no i
ain't got to say it
outright
[Laughter]
yeah cross play cosplay is not easy man
and i think
with some of the other stuff i think
it's actually a blessing in disguise
that
we're not getting cross play at the same
time we're getting the witch queen and
they're gonna have some time to work out
the time to work out the kinks and also
the fall we're gonna get to play halo
without having to worry about how that's
going to overlap with witch queen and i
just think like
this is going to end up working better
for everyone like a spring release of
destiny allows me to focus on that
probably
rather than you know the crazy review
season and all the stuff that's coming
out in the fall
that's going to be crazy mostly halo if
i'm being honest but
yeah i i think i think it's uh it'll
it'll be fine
and and you know maybe ibantus cog maybe
you guys will end up playing more
destiny than you think because uh
now you want to scroll
bro i can't wait that day i'm like i
said i've been more on xbox now that the
series
consoles have been out you know he's
always going to be bouncing keyboard to
the death but
it's going to be so cool to see and that
implementation you know what i said it
just
yeah that is going to be cool doing
strikes together you want to run this 94
what's up
throw me in the backpack eat give me
this grand master let's go solo this do
the work
i gotta practice on those gm's i can
take you through basically any dungeon
other stuff wait for the free stuff
we're just gonna be uh sitting in the
lobby chatting on xbox live and we're
gonna be like carry us
you can keep
i i i i defer to him this man let me
tell you how much was a real sidebar
real quick
like my first dungeon like shattered
throat like
literally e it was the most free
loot i have ever got like just watching
e work solo content i'm like yo you do
this by yourself
you're like yeah just stand over there
do this do that fine eve no problem
whatever we got to do to get it done
shout out to the wizards for a shattered
throne i spent and it's the ogre room
that sucks in there it does yeah
you did your thing though but it's like
when you figure that one out by yourself
i'm like i know exactly how in my mind
this room needs to work
so basically all i want you not to do is
not mess up my plan
all i need you to do is like don't kill
stuff too
fast and kick this sequence off
otherwise i'm in trouble and then i
can't do what i typically do but it's
like
if i can set it up and do what i need to
do pick up stuff like yeah i can i can
take you through a dungeon that's not
hard
so where you want this well already yeah
where you want it yeah
next time put it over here put them like
shoot in the ground like
here right here he had to shoot the
ground and tell me the specifics but it
was funny
but yo shout out to him he's that's
great well uh we'll we'll just sit
around and talk while you run the solo
dungeon and get us that free loot and
then uh
in return we'll introduce you i don't
know if you know this there's a whole
other planet you can visit called
mercury
uh in a place called the lighthouse you
guys can carry me to the lighthouse
[Music]
i'm gonna need that lighthouse carrie i
will help i'm not going to be one of
those who's like i'm literally sitting
in the backpack facing the other
direction like
i will shoot some things i'm just not
going to be the one who can i'm not
going to be top of the leaderboard if i
do it's because i had like one lucky
round but it's like
believe me i'm not completely useless
but i'm also
not going to be the one who is like i'm
not going to be the one who ensures we
win
like the round of trials that's that's
something you don't want to put on my
back
no you'll be put in your work we played
it again you're very humble
you you put anyway i remember doing that
we were playing doing our the
mountaintop days and you were in your
grenade launcher kill back and this man
was beeline into the heavy faster than
i've ever seen but that's another story
but that's for a question man you had to
do it i'm sorry yeah i salute to you you
knew where the heavy spawns when you
were ready
but now he was put in his work he always
he always said shout out to ireland
titan he's like i'll carry you yo bro i
need that lighthouse carrie what's up
man
pc guys i need you guys man i need that
carry travis
i don't need it but yeah we'll help you
yeah i'm mostly excited for across play
to i can play with destin and
some people my clan brian malkowitz and
all that
i have been able to play with uh because
i can't play on pc man
i can't play with those cheaters and
crucible i can't do it
so what about you khan like are you
looking forward to
cross play to just kind of open up who
you play with you got any friends you're
looking to jump back in with
anything crossplay is going to do for
you as i know that's
probably a big thing they're gonna lean
on next season
uh i play at weird times and it's kind
of hard to coordinate with people so
when i jumped when i saw the destiny i
sold a cucumb
that's all i do casually just solo cucum
what do you do
is my first relief hmm yeah honestly so
let's see
it's very soundcloud that's great if
you're playing controllers like
i'd rather play comp because control is
a nightmare
[Laughter]
can be what it's what a shout out all
back for dave real quick he actually
made a good point in reference to the
cross play
party chat yes i agree i i want this
needs to be a solid way
you know for everyone to to be able to
chat together i mean
come on guys game chat it works
perfectly i'm just going to tell
everybody to get in discord that's the
easy part
you can get discord on your phone you
can get discord just about anywhere else
try telling them that yeah because it's
not implemented anybody's own console
that they've got
brick your phone up i have buddies
playing on cameras
understand all the problems here one
console players are not about to get out
their phone and do discord
it just it just is very hard to do and
two then you've got the problem of
they're using discord on their phone so
what are they using as their audio
device
a wired headphone that they got out of a
cereal box or their air pods and it's
just like
complete tin can quality in the chat you
can hear them
breathing and eating and vaping and all
the stuff that they do that annoys the
crap out of me
and then they have no mute button
because they're not using a like full
headset so they can't even mute
themselves while they eat they're
you know a bowl of wheaties and you just
have to listen to that nightmare
yeah i'm like what this is the castle
dude
until december of last year all right
that console
get the discord because the console guys
i know they not pull it out
all of my friends everybody had discord
but those are your people they are
ingratiated with you that is not the
casual brother i'm telling you
the casual guy you're like yo let's get
on discord why can't we stay at xbox
live
party chat why can't we stay in what ps4
i'm telling you they're savage bunch
i just wonder who's eating wheaties in
this man's ear oh my god dude
dude you would not believe it it's gotta
be great just to be that loud you're
gonna be chewing on gravel if you can
hear it there's something there's only
one person in my clan that would like to
do
he will like play like it's like he's
playing like the blade soundtrack in the
background we're playing like sixes
oh there's always that guy there's like
into like the techno industrial metal
right now
what is going on
flawless needs to do uh needs to do a
skit about this because there's always
there's
there's the guy who's playing music
super loud out of his old like boom box
that
sounds like it's halfway across the room
and you can only hear every other lyric
and then there's the guy who's vaping
really loudly just
like like you're playing in party chat
with lord vader with his
with his you know his breathing box
machine on
you got the guy who's just eating crisps
the whole time dude's just popping chips
and crunching your ears
bro there's the guy in my clan that got
his ac on too like too
the dude who's having close conversation
a conversation with this housemate
and he's like yo you were gonna get
carl's jr later and you're just like
dude shut
the f i'm trying to run a raid with you
shut up
like yeah the meatloaf
i never know what she's doing up there i
don't understand that life
yeah khan you need to get off your
mongol throne and come down with us
because we dying out here we xbox one
until
last december of last year so i'm just
saying
i'd say i disagree with cog that this is
a console problem exclusively
it happens on pc2 it's just it's
literally you just got to play with
people you trust and like for me
everything annoys me i'm just super
neurotic and so like
any time somebody does something i'm
learning a little bit i'll mute him i
don't need to hear him like it's just
yeah actually i did somebody did invite
me to play like some
some comp with them and i know the
person invited me and the person
our third was just like non-stop like
vaping and it was like it's like they
were like they
like their mic was like the vape i don't
know what like i don't know if they were
vaping out of the mic
dude vaping is so loud on xbox
the other archetype i forgot to mention
this is discord this is this cool this
is like
oh wow oh so how is that even possible
that's even crazier
i don't know what he's just like in his
like i've got a little mic separation
here and he's vaping in between
think he had like a jewel a jewel themed
like mike it must have been like a mic
that was
out of the mind out of the mic i don't
know what was going on
the other archetype is the guy who's got
the uh the mic
in his mouth or in his nose and you can
just hear him
i hate that one that's maybe the worst
one you can hear his like his
wheezy nasal passages just
in the mic and you're like dude take
that mic and just
move it over here why are you eating it
dude why is it in your full mouth
like my god what i'm hoping for
is oh i'm sorry okay you're good
no i was just gonna say what i was like
the beatles shout out to ty you know
what i thought
what i'm hoping for is look i agree with
you i agree with you
discord is the way to go right
and i'm just hope we know playstation
did the deal with
them right and something they're working
on something with discord we don't know
partnership
please console manufacturers let's have
a discord app option for console guys
right
so this way it's more of a seamless
integration because the
console guys like very like it very
simple and i think
let's be it's the de facto platform you
know that pc guys use and
it's really efficient you know at the
end of the day so that that's what i'm
hoping
and they really get it figured out i'm
very curious to see how bungie
implements it also i want to know how
lobby structure is
you know as far as getting people in and
stuff like that
i i just i've got confidence in money
because they did cross save i thought
pretty well i i want to give them credit
on that i thought they
they did a good job of hailing that so
i'm very curious of the implementation
and i'm i'm ready though just to
again yeah i i think it's going to be
really fragmented i think it's going to
be messy i think i think discord is
going to have a partnership with
with sony but i think that will take
forever to actually become a thing and i
think yeah
even when it does you're going to have
pc to discord figured out
or pc to playstation but then
playstation xbox there's going to be
that gap because xbox is just party chat
and xbox is going down xbox already has
party chat on pc
so you so that will be fit that's
already a thing
the playstation xbox dynamic yeah those
are going to be connected to pc but
they're not going to be able to connect
to each other and that's going to be the
real part
which then comes the reliance of game
chat
and it's trash quality it's always bad
but of course it is because it's
one game dude like discord all they do
is communications that's their whole
company
you're saying you want bungie to make a
game and
run a bungee store and also now they do
like communications professionally like
this shouldn't be something developers
have to worry about
like pl console owners need to get out
of their way and i i'm sure
this is something they're already
thinking about with cross
uh play games becoming more and more
common but like i i just don't think
that there's a good solution right now
i mean to see the playstation was
actually talking to discord is really
good because
discord is the gaming community for
pretty much the entire pc population
it's the way to go
everybody's talking to discord microsoft
tried to buy them this year
you know everybody wants to don't even
talk about nintendo oh god don't even do
that
um i've seen destiny show through it and
i was like
no today is like what is discord yeah
biggest thing i'm going to say yeah i'm
just going to be
if if i'm on twitch or streaming
and somebody wants to play with me if
your audio setup
is like a mess and you're like
if you sound awful in my ears that's it
are you of course what i'm going to say
is hey
skype audio elitist skip a couple of
meals out at restaurants
buy you a reasonable headset make life
easier
it's all you invest in a headset if you
want to jump into some chats
you know think just yeah buy a decent
headset
especially with bluetooth if you can get
one with bluetooth pair with your phone
discord
and also have a wired option they don't
even have to be that expensive buy a
reasonable headset with a mute button
obviously for by the way did you guys
see glad's tweet about the mute button
no what do you say oh [ __ ]
if you have a wireless headset did
anybody in chat see what i'm talking
about if you have a wireless headset
mute your mic when you go to the
bathroom
dudes be loose be loose dude some people
don't mute themselves while they go to
the bathroom on purpose
just so that you can hear it wondering
khan has a question
he's like oh i don't even know what's
happening right now why would you take
your headset into the bad boy
oh my god people that step away people
do it more than you think sir
who says they're in the bathroom you
ever been on a day one race
it's so disgusting
wireless headset gang be yes yeah
[Laughter]
i don't need to hear anybody talk to me
while i'm in the bathroom
nothing's that important i don't i think
you could you i could be at home and
like oh
she's having the baby i'm like well i
gotta go to the bathroom i'll put the
headset down i'm not gonna be listening
to
who is delivering the baby it's not i
don't need to hear
i do not need to hear it it's not that
important
this is the winning lotto numbers
there's no reason
ever to take your headset into the
bathroom
even get off stream when he goes to the
bathroom oh my god
he brings the camera with green screen
behind the toilet
i
just the headset in the splash zone and
like
it takes them over like like if you go
to the bathroom
often with your headset on like how much
is on there for like 30 or 40 days
i mean yeah some of those particles are
floating in the air you bring them out
of the bathroom with you
i mean yeah you shower your body like
you know three four times a week but you
know yes
wipe it off like once uh do you want to
dwipe a headset off no you don't i do
this man does
wet wipes dude i wiped out all that
stuff
my vr headset i got those
interchangeable plates too
so you can wipe down the face of my eyes
i got i got to wipe it off
so these are these are super clean i
don't these never touch my actual skin
but yeah they don't go with you in the
bathroom no just go look up glad's tweet
it's probably not that old
and yeah the dude just that guy had some
digestive issues that day i'm just going
to say
wow it is legit
oh i didn't know that i thought it was
just a snarky tweet no
it was a recipe
somebody needs to not eat an entire
wicker swing sets worth of fiber
and then they'll be a little better off
how many days ago
what the that's wild now yeah that
one that was a good that was a laugh out
loud yeah don't listen
it's not worth it i've i've i've
honestly i've had people do that to me
in xbox live chat on purpose not even an
accident they're like yo listen to this
i'm about to go tear up the toilet
there it's a jungle out there colin's
about to throw us
out we won't be playing again ever again
i'm sorry
to tweet you're gonna have to 73 because
i don't know yeah
yeah i gotta do it everybody's warning
you dude [ __ ] people are warning you
away from this in the comments i think
you're about to
open pandora's box here you got the
monkey pop coming out
don't do it be careful
yeah y'all gotta send me this unless he
deleted it delete it
was it does do i have something is a
laugh and then
the tweet is unavailable i haven't left
uh huh brilliant
no maybe that's not it i don't know yeah
if y'all find it
send it to me oh hold on here we go got
it oh you got you said that yeah
boy i got it i'm not putting it put it
don't put it yeah don't put it you're
not gonna put it in the main
comments but put it in the group discord
chat because i want to listen to that
too
i will not be listening to it live
though because i need to i need to watch
myself all right so yeah i don't know
i'll i'll invest today so yeah when it
comes to cross play respect
the other people's ears you're playing
with that's all i'm saying
just respect them and and apparently
clean your headset
if just don't take it in there in the
first place but still probably clean it
every so often
yeah i mean it definitely you can
replace those uh those ear pads
oh yeah i got covers on mine yeah i know
i'm not using the real ones
[Laughter]
fair fair um but yeah i mean destiny's
got stuff going on and things like that
but i wanted to ask actually if you're
not watching
on video please check it out on video
you know
evonta's youtube channel iron lords
podcast youtube channel wherever we
stream it
uh you got a wall behind you of a lot of
books actually and just to go out with a
little bit of culture after what was
just a whole bunch of not
uh i wanted to see if you had a couple
of recommendations for people because
you've read a
what ton of books from what i gathered
uh if you have like you know top few
books that you can recommend for people
to
pick up that you've you know kind of
made an impact on you for whatever
reason
oh um i guess it depends on the topic
um probably the book i've read the most
will probably have to be hagakure by
sunitomo it's a book on samurai
tomes and uh sayings
um anything by alan watts
or jiru those are like some of my top
authors they're all
they're both anti-gurus um from the
50s the 70s um
i don't i only have like i have less
than 10 books that are fiction
these are they're all non-fiction books
back there so i don't really
read fiction at all and that's why they
make movies
uh so out of the 2000 books are so much
on their
like 99.9 nonfiction
that's nice and history um you read the
way though
well i got i got three copies of that i
love that book
yeah so stuff like that
it's it's it's a good read but
it's short it's pretty fast to get
through uh
books and religion books on philosophy
reference books
books on martial arts the whole like top
shelf on that bookshelf was all martial
arts
the top two shelves actually are
probably all martial arts
nice he's a renaissance man folks
yes yes yeah i was like as i said
culture dead lift a car
could fill up you know a room with
martial arts trophies that'll beat you
up while
he right you know has the intellectual
knowledge to
tear you apart with uh his brain as well
as his brawn
this man is a beast you get one body
you get one mind um you don't let it
dull
in any kind of way if you wanna if you
wanna
enrich in enrich your life as best you
can
you gotta feed it with as many you know
sources of good nutrition as possible
and uh you know the further we move down
this path of like
you know social media and like our
attention being pulled
um the better off your mind will be when
you start to age
you gotta you gotta keep it sharp
because a lot of information you've
received is like you get
battered with it so much you kind of
lose sight of like the
the more important things in life you
know that helps if you were
fewer glad tree glad tweets and more
books that's the
message for today probably there's a
balance to be had there's a balance bet
if you're looking at
twitter like all day long it will
literally turn your brain to mush
and the things you thought were
important five days ago
or a day ago or two hours you're going
to forget in 30 seconds
so you know yeah
yeah i agree question from chat have you
read the ones you've got have you read
them all
uh probably oh from cover to cover
probably like 40 to 50
everything else was like either
reference or i got to the part i needed
and kind of backtracked out or it you
know it's a history book
and um there were certain parts i wanted
to read in the other parts of like i
don't i've retreated this around so many
times in other books so why would i
retreat again
even from their office perspective like
like books on the uh
on um on
chinese history like like chinese war
history
books in japan you know japanese like
war history
um books on like african uh
history you know tribes zoo tribe
stuff like that salute so it all depends
on like
the depth i want to go into the subject
i haven't read many things lately
because of my business
so everything i read now was like it's
an audio book playing while i'm lifting
or when i was driving to work it was
playing like in the car but now since
i've
pretty much worked home everything's
like either um a documentary
or a youtube video on this screen while
i work doing nba stuff in the daytime
so not much not not no newer picks in
the past
16 to 24 months because i work seven
days a week
so absolutely seven day work week how
american
shout out to adam being in chat that he
can finally see chat by the way so
yeah shout out to attic files with jack
and watch this live finally
he hates twitch he's so happy we're on
youtube oh he's
loving this he's like i can finally
watch he despises youtube i think
something with his phone a lot of people
say like when they
remote whatever sometimes twitch on the
phone is a little weird but a salute to
attic yeah man tremendous tremendous
history man love what i heard from the
khan today
dropping knowledge you know what i'm
saying very inspirational story and we
ain't even touched his artwork it's
fire wow like how we got around
everything else that didn't actually get
to your heart
yeah man shout out i shot about one for
against some og stuff he had uh
he had like a clip he kind of did like a
it was like a destiny
version of altered beast and i
loved it and i like that yeah bro that
was fire
like for us older gents you know
ultim beast was a def as a pack in game
for the genesis and
it had like a you know rise from your
gate was an opening that's a classic
line from the game and
you know you basically your character
was dead it was being resurrected so how
he flipped it which was dope
was destiny with the traveler rise from
your grave and then he had like a little
of my guardian which is dope in the in
the art style so salute to you i'm gonna
have to
hit you up sir with some emotes and
potential business opportunities i i've
seen a lot of things look fire and
i don't know podcasts would like to get
some of those services
[Laughter]
i'm always around if you're here for the
week oh for sure
for sure what is your wait list
right now like how's that wait list six
months plus
rush is two months bam two buffs not bad
for the
okay business rush is but two months
to step up that uh you know we're going
to have to hit the iron bank
make that two month pop
we're going to talk about i think we get
priority as uh
being on the show with them
you got to pay the 200 for the disney
fast pass ticket
and then the fast pass on top of that's
another 200 and then we can talk to him
directly
once i get my booking fee for this show
i mean i'm sure i'm making it up yeah
i don't handle it he's good yeah
he's the big youtuber here he handles
all that stuff
he's got that advanced gg money yeah he
got the check he got the outright his
check
he's balling man i'm just so happy and
lucky to associate with him
that's right that's real cute coming
from the last stand media guy
and the sure mike that's like what's
nothing what up you mean i wish that
might cost [ __ ]
you don't even know he doesn't know
because he didn't buy it that's right
you live in that i know how big you
speak of i know that thank you speaker
over here sitting on a tv trailer
i know we didn't get the art which i'm
actually i don't know how we managed to
get around your art so much but it's
actually been kind of a fun show to chat
with you no matter what
but i did want to ask on a couple like
do you have any like favor i know you
have one favorite project so i know
which one because i remember that one
specifically
but any other like top emote stuff that
kind of like
you started goofing around and it really
came together well just any favorite
pieces that you've worked on
and any stories behind them that you've
got that have because you've done a ton
of emotes but like
whether it's an emote that's just like
dude i nailed that one the piece
whatever you got just kind of curious
any favorites of your work that you've
done i know you've done a ton though
uh when you spend all day making steaks
they all look the same
so all the emotes into looking exactly
the same
i made over 5000 so they're all
just i don't think i don't think about
making them anymore
i'm on autopilot it's like muscle memory
almost anywhere
i got the process down to like 20 to 30
minutes for one so
what do you think about these comm
these what these these little art pieces
i got
oh pieces they got behind have you seen
these these raid art pieces they're
they're one for each other yeah yeah
i like them nice salute
well the one that you did for charity i
was gonna say that one's really cool
because your collab with one of the guys
that you know kind of got you back into
it
um how did that go because it's one that
you both
worked on so how does like a co-piece of
art actually work i wanted to ask about
that
oh i drew one full vike version of it
and then i chopped it in half and sent
the other version and they drew the
other half
oh that's cool okay that's cool nice
yeah
still pretty easy i mean that's the only
piece of art i own that i actually have
framed
or print it out for that matter
everything else is a sharp on this
poster or a as a samurai poster or the
the one time i was on dcp they had my
they had like the uh all the portraits
on that one that's what they have like
brain in here
oh ash when she does her art she always
does yeah
it's really cool so so jealousy you guys
that i go a bit that one
the dcp that's like the hall of fame and
i'm like damn
one day i'll get a call yeah i love that
yeah oh amazing like i love like e when
you got your bro
that was so dope because it was your
face reveal and i like how she did the
split
with the oh that was so funny she did
like kind of a cheetah
armor setup which was really really cool
so it looked like it was like still that
like leviathan or something it was it
was
it was dope it was dope so i got it got
his immortalization as well
that's what's up very good that wasn't
the first time they actually drew me
like ash we've been trading art for like
a few years so
oh no it was nice to get like the the
official official up
of me as the drifter nice
you'd make a great drifter if they ever
do a live action
you should yes oh it was hilarious when
they uh when they dropped the trailer
for
this for that season my buddy screencap
of the pictures like i didn't know they
checked your likeness
[Laughter]
well somehow we've wrapped this thing up
pretty well
i think you guys got anything else you
want to ask god no man we
killed it man we kept the man for a good
time great story like i said love the
passion
love the journey really good to hear you
know unique stories and
you know to me or not besides the talent
which is immense that he has you know
i'm saying
i love the actual perseverance i think
that is something a lot of us can can
take
note of and use that for motivation you
know and
um physical bed tool you know what i'm
saying health all that stuff's important
so salute
to the young khan came by the campfire
kilted today
travis got anything else no that's good
that's awesome to
to me meet a guy who does awesome work
in the in the community as always
and uh you're you're probably the most
zen
guest i've ever seen on this show yeah
very
very yes very yeah you carry a lot of
like gravitas and wisdom with you i feel
like uh
you're gonna after this podcast you're
gonna like climb on top of a mountain
and like sit cross-legged and
start like hovering like six sections
you remind me of this other mentor i had
uh what was his name
yoda i'm just kidding uh
[Laughter]
yeah seriously man you are as
i guess that's kind of one of those is
you
you know you've got all your stuff
together so you're just you're chill
you're confident you're humble and yet
there's so much that you've accomplished
and
that you're capable of doing even now
and what you've overcome it's very
very refreshing to see somebody who's
not boisterous or anything like that up
there
just like works their butt off and is
pretty much as impressive of what they
do and what they've been through so just
wanted to thank you for sharing your
journey with us and also just
being here with us for a couple hours in
this ridiculous destiny podcast that we
do
yeah it's been my pleasure i'm glad i
woke up on time
absolutely absolutely too well as we
wrap
up um he's probably not going to say
anything because he's too humble but we
still got to give him a chance to do it
where can people find you what can they
see you if you got any like theme days
going on streams or what to do
um where do people find you if they
haven't seen you before
and what do you typically do actually
that this is a pretty good time
so you can find all my links on con
artists.org
um at least so like everything i do um
but the first of next month
we'll be celebrating my uh four year
anniversary on twitch and my first year
partner uh celebration
um so i'm live seven days a week
uh tonight is free mode friday and movie
night
we watch two like really bad moves on
amazon prime
i like that nice um
let me see i'm here for that i'm here
for that wednesday though the wednesdays
is what i'm about
wednesdays yeah i play wu-tang and like
one month
i play like old uh wait can i when i'm
gonna get the liquid swords album sir i
i i didn't see liquid sources
literally every wednesday okay
okay if you need the
link to my wu-tang playlist like it's
it's yeah i can send it to you
it's like 80 hours long oh
this is all i love this i can talk move
this man let's go to
the real quick real quick favorite
favorite favorite member who
who's
but then i grew up and it was the genius
yeah it's like ways ahead before he
yeah super underrated mc sorry sorry my
caucasian friends we
have to break off into this tattoo i'm
here for
all right we gotta stop this is gonna go
too long moving on
that's that's it uh oh yeah i'll be uh
i'll probably give it away to the tablet
that week too i give away a tablet every
month but nice
i probably give them away another one
for that for that celebration week
if i give away like a nice draw on
tablet every month because
you know i know how hard it is to start
art without a tablet
and uh i don't give i give away a pretty
nice one
because uh being creative and like
having money
they don't want to go hand in hand if i
can like grease the wheels i try to
remote so
they rarely go hand in hand so good for
you
no doubt oh no yeah you guys make it
fortunate enough for me to do that so
well travis you got anything we can
maybe expect from you or a date in the
future where you're like hey fun stuff's
coming
um yeah well i think giza is uh is great
in wu-tang um
[Laughter]
no i've got
[Laughter]
i prefer ghost face killer myself but
anyway um
chip let's go uh yeah so i've got i've
got a review coming out uh later today
uh chris tales it is a uh
love letter to the jrpg genre so if
you're into that
you'll be able to read my review or
watch the video later today
um and other than that i'm just going to
try to get some destiny in you can
you can follow me on uh twitter at uh
tie guy travis where i'm sure i will
have some takes on
my uh late review of of this um
uh moment of triumphs or whatever the
heck they're calling it these days
of heroes solstice of heroes thank you
sorry i always forget i always forget
what this one's called
um but yeah i'll i'll have my
impressions there and
you can you can also find me here
sometimes i'm on this show the last word
uh also i was on a great podcast this
past sunday
uh the iron lords podcast uh with uh
some some awesome uh paris was there
and and uh we got into it we got into it
guys over this
uh this latest controversy so watch
watch that if
if you uh care at all about um the world
and
yeah she did your thing brother i was
glad i'm glad you pulled up
thanks that was awesome man yeah
respecting your perspective i got to get
back in the realm too man it's been a
minute
it's been a minute absolutely yeah no we
need we need another guy at the cookout
you know what i mean
anyway that's me thanks guys what about
you man what do you got cooking
speaking of it yeah well first of all
again salute to khan for pulling up man
fun show great great topics i can talk
to this man i'll demand
of of my my bracket so i can respect
this
type of discussions you know especially
the show run run show stuff the
attention the gaming art he's killing it
man so i love to hear those type of
things on
last word but yeah for me man's been
it's been busy but um
obviously you know saluted everybody was
showing love for me coasting with
defining duke
it's been real fun maddie's been awesome
i've been really enjoying it man
it's a fun show it's a fun show and then
we're just trying to you know make it
our own so salute to that
um hopefully like i said patreons need
new episodes up
already if not you know don't want to
wait you know
you try to pay that and get that sunday
for free 99
you know how much they got to pay to get
that early though what is it
well we could think it's like two bucks
or five bucks yeah that's much yeah it's
not like not much
yeah okay if you want to support you
know by all means like i said last time
he had been doing anything
so yeah you got that and obviously iron
lords podcast man every sunday is the
lord's day 1 p.m
eastern we will have the young brother
andrew
alliance very cool up and coming content
created tech reviews
very analog also a destiny guy also a
destiny guy
so yeah check him out he's on the rise
um he's getting
i think he he was actually on kind of
funny ex-cast at one time with paris
and um those guys gary wood and those
guys so check him out i think this
young brother is super talented and no
one really knows him yeah i think he's
gonna be a star so check him out
and uh yeah there's this uh new youtube
podcast that uh
destiny podcast that i'm liking man like
yo it's these three dudes and
there's one cheetah there's a ninja on
it and this guy that wears a tie
and i like them on youtube man i'm
really feeling this new show
you know so i want to support i want to
settle
i want to support man i heard about
these last word guys man
so that's a little always fun to salute
everybody again
we know the adjustment you know
obviously on twitch private we're going
to try to give this a run
see how it is and already you know we're
seeing some and for the first debut it's
kind of
kind of cool to see a lot of the faces
that we we know and love still come over
regardless of the platform so
much love and uh yeah man thanks for e
for making it happen then
what else you got going on sir uh for me
i'm kind of
prepping for a vacation so getting stuff
recorded so while i'm gone i'm gonna be
gone early august so
two fridays i'm probably gonna miss
we'll see if these two put together
something while i'm gone
might be on the iron lords podcast
channel so make sure you guys go follow
them over there
follow thai guy travis and please go
check out our awesome guest the
renaissance man
truly yes yeah khan thank you
so much for joining us man like
so cool to like hear more about you
because you already like you know hang
out in your streams and see the art that
you do and you know there's a lot of
talent there and then you learn more
about you and it's just even more
impressive so
thank you for spending the time for
cutting out the time with us i'll get
you that fee afterwards i'm just kidding
gotta get that appearance over there
no but seriously thank you for your time
today it's been an absolute pleasure
getting a chance to chat with you
it's been a um no doubt but that's
pretty much all i got so yeah for me
it's ibontist you know twitch twitter
youtube
apparently all of the places so if you
guys find anything from me thank you
guys for always hanging out of course
um if you guys are watching this on
youtube you ever want to
uh hang out we always appreciate having
all of you guys in here but for this
episode we'll probably wrap this one up
here it's not twitch so we're not going
to go raid anybody since i can't do that
some things they got to work on but
there's some cool stuff over here
yeah it'd be cool to know if you could
send somebody off to somebody else but
for this episode number 159
very good one next week we're going to
have drewski on so definitely going to
be
incognito sandbox bag pvp guides i'll
just like start the podcast and walk out
of the room
yeah that one that segment may
apparently make a begrudging return
other than that today's episode has been
a blast thank you guys for all the fun
the laughs chat you guys have been great
and sir khan thank you so for episode
number 159
we appreciate it and it has been